Hallo, ich bin auch wieder da, aber nun müssen wir tatsächlich mal was sinnvolles machen.
Wir müssen nämlich einen ordentlichen neuen Handyvertrag raussuchen.
Das heißt wir müssen ein paar Anbieter vergleichen.
Ich vermute mal, dass alle anderen Anbieter, außer so die großen drei, eh wegfallen werden,
aber...
Ja, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Du hattest recht, es gibt anonymen Twitch IRC Login, hat mich nur Monate gekostet.
Warum hat dich das Monate gekostet?
Den Zusammenhang verstehe ich jetzt nicht so genau, weil, unabhängig davon, ob es das
gibt oder nicht, ich habe ja sogar in einem Video schon mal gezeigt, also in einem Stream
schon mal gezeigt, wie man das benutzt.
Ja, das habe ich auch bei mir im Stream damals gezeigt, dass man das machen muss, das habe
ich auch nicht gecheckt erst.
Justin Fan muss man nehmen, ja genau, ich erinnere mich, Justin Fan, und dann kriegst du aber
alle Nachrichten IRC-mäßig mit Newline terminiert oder irgendwie sowas, wir haben uns das angeguckt.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, IRC, Health IRC, ne, was, DHL, Gbaited, wieder Zeit für
Streams, ok, keine Ahnung, wo das ist, Twitch Chat, ok, ne, keine Ahnung, ich weiß auch
nicht mal, wie das hieß.
Ach du hast es gefunden, ne, wie gesagt, ich wüsste jetzt den Titel auch gerade nicht
mehr.
Joa, ja, also Leute, ich wollte euch was zeigen, genau, und zwar, hups, ne, nochmal starten
geht nicht, das ist dafür nicht ausgelegt, das ist, das ist zu kaputt, dieses Image
Overlating, das kann man nicht mehrfach starten, das klappt nicht, wenn man das versucht mehrfach
zu starten, dann, RIP, ich hab was gefunden auf Reddit, irgendwo auf, ich glaub, ich glaub
auf dem Self-hosted Reddit oder so, wir hatten es doch letztens davon, wie man oder wo man
eine kostenlose VM bekommen kann, bei welchen Cloud-Anbietern, und das haben ja die meisten
Cloud-Anbieter in Freed hier, aber so wirklich ne VM, die man quasi 24-7 laufen lassen kann,
und nix bezahlen muss, gibt es nicht so oft, ich hab ja damals gezeigt, dass Oracle Cloud
hat sowas, Freed hier, ein relativ großzügiges Freed hier, ich vermute allerdings, ich hab
jetzt aber noch was anderes gefunden, zeig ich euch gleich, ein relativ großzügiges
Freed hier hatten die, nämlich du bekommst sogar, sogar zwei VMs mittlerweile, ok, das
ist neu oder, war das letzte Mal nicht nur eine, nein, du bekommst sogar zwei, zwei VMs,
kannst du bekommen, mit 1GB RAM, was relativ großzügig ist, und irgendwie geschärter,
geschärter CPU, oder du kannst auch noch irgendwie ne armbasierte VM an, also das ist
tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht für kostenlos, aber ich hab noch was anderes gefunden, was
auf den ersten Blick nicht unbedingt besser aussieht, aber anders, und zwar hab ich das
auf Reddit, ich glaub im Self-hosted Subreddit gefunden, Fly.io, kannte ich bis zu dem Zeitpunkt
gar nicht, ich hab da mal auf YouTube geguckt und hab festgestellt, so unbekannt scheint
der Service gar nicht zu sein, ich kannte ihn bis dahin nicht, und die haben, wenn man mal
ein paar Pricing guckt, wenn man mal ein paar Pricing guckt, haben die auch, zwar nur 100,
100, einmal 250 MB VM, aber du kannst auch bis zu drei Total VMs machen, ist auch nicht
so schlecht, mit dem Free Tier, bei Oracle muss man die Kreditkarte hinterlegen, das
probieren wir doch jetzt mal aus Leute, das testen wir mal, ich hab das noch nicht ausprobiert,
need an account, 10 minute mail, ja perfekt, perfekt email, genau die, brauche ich mal
mein bestes Name, Kekl Omega Lul, ich denk mal schnell ein Passport aus, was die hoffentlich
fressen werden, so, sehr gut, create my account, ah add a payment method, ja for free, ich
wills for free tryen, ok man muss es doch nicht enden, Megre Patron 48, freust du dich
schon auf Dienstag, wenn Battlefield 20 für PS5 gratis wird, ja ein bisschen vielleicht,
hatten die Paypal, Hobbyplan for free, get started with our free tier, man braucht keine
Kreditkarte anscheinend, ok und man muss auch aus irgendwelchen Gründen die email Adresse
nicht bestätigen, das ist schon mal ein bisschen massive, massive debate, ok keine Ahnung
wie es jetzt weiter funktioniert, warte, warte das wird anscheinend, moment PS5, nee moment
auf der PS5 ist es doch nicht gratis, ich dachte das ist Teil von irgendeinem Playstation
plus Pass oder sowas, ja genau, es wird Dienstag gratis, wirklich, ach nur Dienstag oder sowas,
also nur Dienstags mal, nee komm zu Playstation plus, nee das wird nicht gratis in dem Sinn,
der Playstation plus muss ja trotzdem bezahlen, so und jetzt kann man hier was auch immer machen,
jetzt habe ich keine Ahnung was man jetzt hier machen kann, aber man kann angeblich
jetzt hier eine VM erstellen und die benutzen, let's go, Lordschwepp CLI, ey ok, ich bin
jetzt sehr planlos und jetzt wie lege ich jetzt eine VM an, ich habe das nur vorhin
auf Reddit gefunden und ich dachte nee ich zeige es euch mal kurz, aber das ist ja wieder
absoluter 5 head shit, hier Machines, ich will eine Linux Maschine haben, ah das sind
Firecracker VMs, Firecracker das ist so eine Virtualisierungsplattform von Amazon, war das
Amazon, so minimal KVM VMs sind das, so, random machine app, ok Leute ich habe jetzt seriously
keinen Plan wie das funktioniert, wie auch immer, ok ich habe keinen Plan, ich habe wirklich
keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert, das sieht jetzt eher nicht nach vollständigen VMs aus
sondern eher nach irgendwelchen Containern wobei es ja Firecracker VMs sind, ok keine
Ahnung, das muss ich mir im Detail angucken, man kann mit Terraform das ganze wohl auch
verwalten, aber so eine VM wo man sich dann einfach einloggen kann und Zeug drauf installieren
kann und so ist es ja nicht, das gucke ich mir mal bei Gelegenheit an, will jetzt auch
nichts leaken oder sonst was, ja, also keine Ahnung wie das funktioniert, zumindest haben
die ein Free Tier, was war das, Fly, Fly CTL, ok Fly CTL, Machines und jetzt Run, Help,
Verify your email address, alles klar mache ich, kein Problem, Verify email address, wann
machen wir Kubernetes Stells im Stream, bald, bald Leute, mach mal bald, Machines, no Machines,
das ist extrem Sixhead Time, wie auch immer das funktioniert, ich wollte euch eigentlich
nur kurz zeigen, es ist nicht ewig, ok Help, yes, you need payment information to continue,
jepp cock, ich wusste es doch, ok auch da nur mit Kreditkarte, jebaited, ja, massive,
massive jebaited, ich hab schon gedacht man kann das ganze ohne Kreditkarte, nope, mein
kennst du, disposable root servers, nee was ist das, hackers choice login, segfold offers
free unlimited root servers, a new server for every, ach für jede SSH Connection, nee,
das ist aber wahrscheinlich nur wenn man was kurz braucht, so nach dem Motto ich brauch
einen Server wo ich 24 7 was drauf laufen lasse, ist nicht so sinnig, ok kenne ich nicht,
ist aber interessant, wusste ich nicht, dass es das gibt, wenn man mal ganz kurz eine Linux
Kiste, eine halbwegs anonyme Linux Kiste für irgendwas braucht, ist gar nicht verkehrt,
das stimmt wohl, das gucken wir uns heute an, wie das ist mit Verträgen, weil ich brauche
noch einen Vertrag und warum brauche ich noch einen Vertrag, ganz einfach, kann ich an der
Stelle mal kurz erzählen, ich bin noch zwei Wochen bei meinem aktuellen Arbeitgeber, ok
man ist eigentlich immer beim aktuellen Arbeitgeber, da wo ich schon jetzt über 10 Jahre bin,
bin ich ja nur noch zwei Wochen, ab 1. April geht es bei dem anderen Laden los und ich
habe aktuell noch das Handy von der Firma, was ist das, ich habe hier ein iPhone 11 glaube
ich, keine Ahnung, ich weiß gar nicht ob man das erkennt, wie sieht ein iPhone 11 von hinten
aus, das hat nur zwei Kameras, iPhone 11, oh hier so, ja das sieht richtig aus, ok, ich
weiß, ja so sieht das von hinten aus, also ein iPhone 11, so und das habe ich hier noch
im Einsatz von denen, ich habe mir jetzt ein iPhone 14 gekauft, das liegt hier rum, äh
und theoretisch habe, hatte ich dafür auch eine Hülle bestellt, Moment ich muss mal kurz
bei Amazon gucken, wo die bleibt, Sekunde, your orders, iPhone case, nee das kam angeblich
wohl an, ich weiß nicht wo ich es hingeschmissen habe, muss ich mal gucken, irgendwo in die
Ecke werde ich es gepfeffert haben, also es ist wohl schon angekommen, na gut, ja ok,
das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken, zumindest danke Leute für die ganzen Subs hier, schlechtes
WLAN, sehr gute Subscription, exellent, du brauchst gescheit ein Access Point, habe ich
auch in einem der letzten Streams was gescheites gezeigt, es gibt sehr gute Access Points,
die man sich kaufen kann bei Ebay, die besser sind als, also auch von Features her als die
meisten äh anderen Dinger, die die Leute so am Start haben, ja also wie gesagt, ich
habe aktuell ein Handy von der Firma gestellt, brauchst du denn mobile Daten, ja so ungefähr
20G, das können wir uns gleich mal aufschreiben, was ich haben will, ich kann euch das erzählen,
also ich will ungefähr 20G, habe ich so mal über einen Daumen gepackt, ungefähr 20G
pro Tag im Monat, bin ja schon ab und zu mal unterwegs, sei es jetzt weil ich doch mal
ins Büro fahre oder weil ich im Zug sitze eine Weile und die Bahn zu spät ist und ich
dann YouTube Videos kocke und sonst was, ja also ungefähr 20G, zumindest ich habe aktuell
ein iPhone 11 von der Firma gestellt und ich wechsle ja allerdings das Unternehmen zum
1.
April bzw. zum 30.
3.
oder 31.
Wieviel Tage hat eigentlich der März, 31 ja hier, hier wechsle ich dann, ne hier kann
ich gleich wechseln, ich wechsle da, 3.
April, ok, so und ja mach ich, mach ich gleich alles, ich gucke mir gleich mal Handyanbieter
an und das muss ich abgeben, was ich machen kann ist, weil ich ja schon so lange da bin
und ich auch die Handynummer für 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung benutze und viele Leute auch diese Handynummer,
die einzige Handynummer ist die sie von mir haben, also das von der Firma gestellte Handy
mit dem von der Firma gestellten Vertrag, haben die gesagt ich kann meine Rufnummer übernehmen,
also ich kann meine Rufnummer portieren lassen, wenn ich das will, das heißt ich brauche jetzt
ein Vertrag, ein neues Handy habe ich schon, ich brauche jetzt ein Vertrag wo ich das hin
portieren lassen kann, dass ich das die nächsten 2 Wochen noch machen kann, weil ich bin bloß
noch 2 Wochen auf der Arbeit, ich bin zwar offiziell erst am 31.
Weg, allerdings bin ich schon, allerdings bin ich ja schon, weil ich noch 6 Tage Resturlaub
habe und noch 15 Stunden auf meinem Rufbereitschaftskonto, bin ich ja schon weg am 1, 2, 3, 4, hier arbeite
ich eh nicht montags, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, eigentlich da schon, weil 15 Stunden sind ja 2 Tage, eigentlich
könnte ich zu richtig am 17. schon weg sein, so das ist glaube ich noch besser, dann habe
ich nämlich einfach noch mal 2 Wochen Urlaub, zwischendurch, das war schon mal extrem nice,
also hier entweder bin ich schon, entweder bin ich 17.
weg oder spätestens 22, also entweder ist der 17.
letzte Tag, das heißt ich habe jetzt noch nächste Woche Zeit, übernächste Woche Zeit
einen neuen Vertrag abzuschließen und meine Rufnummern portieren zu lassen, dass ich die
behalten kann, so und deswegen brauche ich einen neuen Handytarif, ganz einfach.
Ich musste eine Fritzbox als Accesspoint umbauen, weil Kupferleitungen in der Wand abgestorben
sind, sterben dann Kupferleitungen in der Wand ab, ne Internet und Mobilfunk will ich nicht
vom gleichen, also brauche ich nicht vom gleichen Anbieter, ich mein ich könnte es machen, weil
ich Bavodafon bin, aber ne, ich will das unabhängig voneinander haben, dass ich das alles je nachdem
wie ich will schnell wechseln kann und mir nicht um tausend Sachen Gedanken machen muss.
Sim.de klingt nach irgendeinem Scam, aber ne anscheinend nicht, ja Vodafon hat auch Probleme,
aber da kann das Wlan ja gut sein, aber dein Provider trotzdem scheiße bauen, ja ich hab
auch öfters Probleme mit Vodafon.
Ok, Telekom gucken wir auch gleich, warum, warum, warum sind die anderen so kacke von
der Abdeckung her oder wie ist das so, weil Telekom ist glaub ich auch mit Abstand das
teuerste, SMS Flat brauche ich nicht, ja Windows Logik muss man nicht versuchen zu durchschauen,
aha, aha, hier ist kaum O2 oder Vodafon, wieso was hast du gegen O2, wie gesagt interessiert
mich, weil ich will jetzt ja nicht zu irgendeinem kacke Anbieter gehen, wobei letztendlich wahrscheinlich
unter dem Strich sind alle irgendwie kacke, also mein Nutzungsverhalten ist relativ einfach
zu beschreiben, ich brauch ungefähr 20GB, also 10-20GB oder sagen wir mal so, wenn ich
total übertreibe 10-30GB, aber 20, 20 ist denke ich ganz guter Guess, ja, handyvertrag.de
jetzt gehts aber los, beste Internetseiten hier von der URL, also dann was ich gerne
haben würde ist die Möglichkeit eSIM und nach Möglichkeit auch MultisIM, weil ich kann
euch das auch erklären warum, ich nehme ja meine Rufnummer mit jetzt zu einem eigenen
Vertrag und ich habe ein eigenes iPhone, aber es kann ja durchaus sein, dass ich wieder
ein Handy gestellt bekomme vom neuen Arbeitgeber, was heißt es kann so sein, das wird so sein,
ich weiß, dass das so ist und das hat dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal eine neue Nummer
oder so, mal gucken, die können mich auch wie auch immer da eintragen, mal gucken, aber
die wollen ja ihre Apps vorinstalliert haben, keine Ahnung, also wahrscheinlich kriege
ich ein eigenes Handy und das kann man aber auch privat benutzen, das eigene Handy, das
vom Arbeitgeber das Handy, so und ich hab mir überlegt, ich mein, wenn ich jetzt, ich hab
hier schon ein eigenes iPhone gekauft, dann könnte ich einfach dort eine zweite SIM rein
machen, entweder als SIM oder als eSIM und dann habe ich einfach schlicht ergreifend
zwei Geräte, das eine kann ich quasi beruflich und privat benutzen mit der gleichen Nummer
und das andere ist halt mein privates Handy, was ich überall hin mitnehme, das heißt die
Sache, mehrere SIM-Karten für die gleiche Nummer wäre in dem Fall denke ich mal schon
sehr praktisch und die Variante als eSIM natürlich auch, dass man nicht mehr mit SIM-Karten rum
handeln muss und dass man im Zweifelsfall, je nachdem, was die haben, dann das jeweils
andere benutzen kann, ja dann einfach Telekom bestellen, da geht alles, das habe ich auch
schon mitgekriegt, allerdings ist die Telekom auch mit Abstand am teuersten, mal gucken,
was es sonst noch so gibt, so, die Seite klingt übrigens übelst Scamast, höh ich das schon
sehe, Handyvertrag.de man, das sieht irgendwie schon ein bisschen weisslich, LTE, ah das ist
nur LTE, me, kein 5G, warum, warum nicht, warum nicht, das funktioniert nicht, das funktioniert
nicht, also erstens müsste sich das dazu zeitlich irgendwie ein bisschen überschneiden,
was es nicht macht und die werden mir sicherlich eine neue Nummer und neues Handy geben, 5G
voll sinnlos, naja Moment, 5G ist nicht sinnvoll von der Geschwindigkeit allein, sondern bestimmt
in Zukunft auch für die Abdeckung und wenn du einen Vertrag hast, die nur oder meinen
die damit nicht 5G Connectivity sondern LTE Geschwindigkeit, weil wenn jetzt beispielsweise
hier steht jetzt ja, hier steht jetzt ja 10G LTE, heißt das dann auch ich kann mich nicht
zu 5G Masten connecten oder heißt das die Geschwindigkeit des LTE, 5G Abdeckung, naja
man muss jetzt ja nicht unbedingt von jetzt aktuellem Ist-Stand ausgehen, sondern vielleicht
auch mal 2-3 Jahre in die Zukunft, also jetzt irgendwie was noch kaufen wo ich keinen Zugang
zu 5G Sachen bekomme ist doch auch doof oder, was soll der Vertrag können, also bis jetzt,
bis jetzt habe ich nur für mich festgestellt, dass ich ungefähr 20GB brauche im Monat,
also weniger geht auch, aber mit 20G bin ich auf jeden Fall auf der sicheren Seite, Möglichkeit
für eSIM und mindestens 2 SIM Karten wären auch praktisch, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht,
ich will mit denen ehrlich gesagt auch dann das nicht so sehr verbandeln, also das einzige
was sich Mobilfunk technisch die letzten Jahre über zu tun hat ist tatsächlich Aldi Talk,
da habe ich meiner Mutter nämlich einen Prepaid Vertrag gekauft, bei Aldi Talk, sowas habe
ich der hier, sowas irgendwie, Kombipaket S habe ich, da bin ich sehr wenig, wobei doch
kann tatsächlich sein, ich glaube irgendwie sowas habe ich der gekauft, die benutzt das
Handy im Endeffekt so gut wie gar nicht und wenn überhaupt dann guckt die da irgendwie
einmal in der Woche kurz was nach im Internet und das wars und nimmt hauptsächlich Gespräche
an wenn überhaupt, also das hat die das natürlich sehr günstig, wobei für mich das ganze nicht
reicht, 3GB ist definitiv zu wenig, damit komme ich auf gar keinen Fall hin, 12G wäre
das Minimum, also 12G wäre wirklich das Minimum was ich nehmen würde, der Rest ist mir ein
bisschen zu wenig, also das ich weiß nicht, das spricht mich jetzt nicht an, komm wir
gucken mal, welche, wir können das doch ganz einfach einschränken, die haben doch bestimmt
auch keine Möglichkeit, eSIM, Multisim oder sonstige Geschichten, also wir gucken mal,
welche Anbieter haben Multisim Anbieter, da gibt es doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viele
und dementsprechend können wir das doch schon einschränken, was da sinnvoll ist und was
nicht, Kongstar, aber Kongstar hat keine mehreren SIM Karten oder, ich will auf jeden Fall die
Möglichkeit haben mehrere SIM Karten zu haben, für die gleiche Nummer, Kongstar hat Multisim,
wirklich, Kongstar hat Multisim, die Multisim bei Kongstar, haben die eSIM, achja tatsächlich,
dein Vertrag jetzt auf zwei Geräten nutzen, neu bei Kongstar, Multisim, ok interessant,
das ist, ok hier die Computer Bild weiß Bescheid, was darf es kosten, das habe ich mir noch keine
Gedanken zugemacht, ich gucke einfach mal was es denn so normalerweise kostet, wenn ich was
haben will mit 20G und mehreren SIM Karten und dann mal gucken was das beste Preis Leistung
hat, das heißt du bezahlst, das heißt du bezahlst 50 Euro im Monat fürs Handy Paul, das erscheint
mir jetzt doch relativ viel, ok lass mal kurz checken, einloggen und bestellen, deine Multisim
verwalten, nutze mit der flexiblen Multisim Option deinen Vertrag auf mehreren Geräten
gleichzeitig mit einem Vertrag einer einzigen Rechnung, ok ein Vertrag, eine Rufnummer,
eine Rechnung, ah, siehste, das ist schon mal doof, ich hätte gerne die Möglichkeit
das auch als eSIM zu machen, gut ich meine das wäre jetzt nicht so wild, das wäre jetzt
nicht so wild, solange ich, solange ich eine von beiden Karten, also eine von beiden Karten
als eSIM machen kann, Kongstar, kann Kongstar eSIM, da blick ich wieder nach durch wie was
wie wo geht, Tarife mit eSIM, ok da geht das aber mit Multisim nicht zusammen anscheinend,
das verwirrt mich jetzt schon wieder, lass mal kurz gucken was kostet denn bei denen
zumindest irgendwie was halbwegs, halbwegs passendes, schon mal wieder so aufgebaut dass
ich überhaupt nicht weiß was die mir sagen wollen, die Telekom, die Telekom das kann
weiß ich, die Telekom kann so gut wie alles, allerdings, also auch die teuersten, so wähle
deine Allnet Flat, ich brauch keine Allnet Flat, ich telefonier so gut wie gar nicht
über Mobilfunk mit meinem Handy, aber wahrscheinlich musst du hier irgendwie, das ist Datenvolumen
ok, ganz schön, da ist es ja sogar bei der Telekom fast noch billiger, wie sieht es denn
überhaupt bei dir zwecks Netz aus, wie soll es bei mir aussehen zwecks Netz, wie jetzt
was, was da besonders ausgebaut ist bei mir in der Ecke, ich wohne Frankfurt, ich wohne
in Frankfurt beziehungsweise in der Nähe von Frankfurt, ich glaube hier ist alles ganz
gut, ganz gut ausgebaut, das einzige wo ich jeden Tag Probleme habe, jeden Tag wo ich
im Zug fahre ist in mein Tal am Bahnhof wo ich irgendwie keinen Empfang habe für mal
kurze Zeit, wenn du jung bist, oh too young, da bin ich nicht jung genug für, oh too
young hat auch was ab 60 plus, aber so alt bin ich auch noch nicht, ok also, also ich
glaube 8 Gigabyte ist mir ein bisschen wenig wenn ich ehrlich bin, so 18, 18 wäre denke
ich ganz gut, komm wir gucken jetzt mal so als, wir gucken mal so als Base Geschichte
bei der Telekom, was es da kosten wird, Smartphone Tarife, einfach das wir mal wissen, was so
das teuerste ist was es so gibt, so also ich brauche nur eine, ne Moment, wie viele Karten,
Moment ich möchte einen Vertrag mit mehreren Karten, das ist aber was anderes hier, Mobilfunk
in Deutschland ja, ok Leute 5 Gigabyte wollen die ernsthaft schon 35 Euro und dann Tarife
ohne Laufzeit ja, ist das mit, das ist nicht mit Handy oder, ne ne Gerät hinzufügen kann
man auch machen, aber 75 Euro im Monat, also ganz im Ernst, irgendwann ist das auch mal
gut, das ist Leute 50 Euro im Monat, wenn ich 20G haben will, das ist schon on, plus
jetzt haltet euch mal fest, da kommen ja noch 5 Euro oben drauf, weil ich zwei SIM Karten
haben will, muss man bei Check24, das machen wir jetzt, Check24, sehr gut, sehr gut, exzellent,
wir vergleichen das jetzt bei Achtung Flashbang Time Leute, aber das ist ja abartig teuer,
ich mein, einmalig nochmal 40 Euro oben drauf, 50 Euro unlimited, aber unlimited kostet nur
85 Euro, du hast es wahrscheinlich mal abgeschlossen irgendwann vor 10 Jahren oder so, 15 Euro
Rabattcode, das heißt dann habe ich ungefähr die Kosten von der zweiten SIM Karte wieder
drinne, so also pass mal auf, Tarif auswählen und jetzt noch die zweite SIM Karte dabei,
was, was, was wollen die von mir, ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was das Popup mir sagen
soll jetzt, ich will das nicht, ich will eine Multisim, aber ich habe das falsche angeklickt,
lull, ich habe Multisim gelesen, aber das hier angeklickt, ok das ist natürlich Fail,
das hier wollte ich eigentlich anklicken, brauche ich alles, brauche ich alles nicht,
internationale SMS, ja klar, weil ich auch noch so viele SMS verschicke, so in den Warenkorb
und am Ende kostet es jetzt, Alter ist das teuer Mann, guckt euch das mal an, 55 Euro
und als würde es noch nicht reichen, 55 Euro, nochmal 40 Euro einmalig, es ist doch nicht
teuer genug, dass es 55 Euro im Monat kostet, warum ist das auf einmal Triple SIM, ich will
doch nur eine zweite haben, aber immerhin keine Versandkosten, da habe ich nochmal Glück gehabt,
da habe ich nochmal Glück gehabt, dass es keine Versandkosten hat hier, du hast die Laufzeit
weggemacht, ja das ist auch Absicht, Winsim, oh ne, Winsim, die skippe ich, passt mal auf,
da gehe ich nett hin, ich weiß die anderen haben auch keine wirklich besseren Bewertungen,
aber bei den anderen ist es so, dass nicht nur das reine Mobilfunkzeug bewertet wird,
sondern immer auch alles, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel bei der Telekom guckst, dann
sind die auch scheiße bewertet, aber das ist halt das komplette Telekomladen und hier weißt
du, es ist mehr oder weniger, was, ok, ok, die Bewertung klingt schon äußerst pepega,
den Datenverlust nach zwei Tagen trotz WLAN, hä, was will er mir sagen, ok, am zweiten
Tag des neuen Monats war das Datenvolumen angeblich plötzlich aufgebraucht, obwohl zu Hause im
Telekom, ohne viele Minder zu sein, ach so meint er das, ach so, braucht sonst mein Datenvolumen
ja auch sein, es ist doch durchaus möglich, dass er es wirklich verkackt hat, also dass
er es wirklich verkackt hat. Wo gibt es eine Karte? Mobilfunk Abdeckung Deutschland. Logitech
Anbieter, ok, das ist gut, das gucken wir uns jetzt an, äh, was ist das, was zum, gibt
es da irgendwie, meint, gibt es da irgendwie so eine Vergleichskarte oder? Freenet ist
doch alles, Freenet ist doch das, was früher mal E plus mitgemacht hat, oder? Also auch
quasi O2 jetzt, oder? War es nicht so, dass es nicht nur drei Anbieter gibt? Es gibt,
es gibt die Telekom, es gibt Vodafone, das ist das, was früher mal Mannesmann oder so
gewesen ist, und dann gibt es glaub noch Telefonica, oder? Warte mal, das stand doch, das stand
doch eben, also das ist O2 und sowas. Mobilfunk Monitoring, auf geht's. Ups, jetzt habe ich
irgendeinen Mistcopy pasted. Gigabitgrundbuch, die haben immer die abgedrehtesten Benamungen
für ihr Zeug, Mann. Gigabitgrundbuchbund.de, die denken sich da immer Dinger aus, man muss
ja, man muss ja aber schon eins zu Gute halten, also im Ausdenken von solchen komischen Wörtern
sind die wirklich, sind die wirklich geil. Mobilfunk Monitoringkarte, ach so, das Gigabitgrundbuch,
das kenne ich sogar, das habe ich in einem meiner Videos mal erwähnt, das ist was, was
im Zuge der Gigabitstrategie, der deutschen Gigabitstrategie eingeführt werden soll,
dass man nachvollziehen kann, wie gut das ganze vorwärts geht. Das habe ich sogar mal
in einem Video erwähnt, finde ich an sich eine sinnvolle Geschichte, das Dumme ist nur,
dass die glaube ich wie der Mobilfunk dabei zählen und Mobilfunk ist eine wichtige Geschichte,
aber es ersetzt kein Gigabitglasfaseranschluss daheim. Telekom gleich D1, Vodafone gleich
D2 und dann noch O plus, O2, E plus, ja genau, so habe ich das auch im Hinterkopf, ok, zeig
her. Mit was haben die das gemacht, das müssen wir uns gleich mal kurz angucken. Das Mapbox,
nee das ist nicht Mapbox, Mapbox ist das viel zu hässlich. Was benutzen die denn,
lasst mal kurz gucken, Map Server, irgendwas eigenes. Argus, das kenne ich, das habe ich
schon mal gehört. Build interactive webmasters, Argus online, ok das da, verwenden die wohl
für Maps. Alter wie viel laden die denn da bitte schön runter, das hört ja gar nicht
aus. Bootstrap, Webfonds, ok, ich würde, sag mal Chat, bin ich zu blöd, kann man nicht
normalerweise das hier, kann man das nicht normalerweise runter machen und dann stehen
die URLs da, so, ach nee, ach nee passt doch, nee im Moment, hä, das sieht irgendwie komisch
aus. Ah, das habe ich gemeint, so sieht das normalerweise aus, ok, ok ist auch egal was
die feinden. Additionalkacheln.css, ja da weißt du Bescheid. Ok, guck mal mal, da weiß
man aber nicht welche, Moment, da kann man nach Anbieter filtern, nee gell, hier, ah,
ach so, ok, lass mal gucken, wie ist es denn in Hanau so, ich weiß, ich weiß, wir machen,
wir vergleichen mal zwei Sachen, einmal Hanau und dann zwei Ecken, oder eine Ecke wo ich
ganz gerne wandern gehe, das ist so ein bisschen außerhalb. 5G DSS 5G, ich habe keine Ahnung
was es ist, huge leak, ja, so, also, ok, Vodafone hat hier 5G DSS, Telekom hat hier 5G, was habe
ich denn aktuell gerade, zeig mal, ich guck mal kurz auf mein iPhone drauf, wartet mal,
ich mal gucken, LTE, Moment, das iPhone 11 hat gar kein 5G, oder, ich kann eh nur maximal
LTE haben bei dem, welches iPhone hat da ein 5G, ah, ab dem 12er, ok, ja, aber ich habe
ja den 14er hier, das 14er kann es auf jeden Fall, also ok, hier heißt, das heißt, hier
heißt, die Telekom hat 5G ausgebaut, Vodafone hat Long Range 5G und O2 hat ein bisschen 5G,
aber zum größten Teil nur LTE, aber ich finde, man sieht schon, dass die O2 Abdeckung schlechter
ist als von den anderen beiden, die anderen, also die Telekom ist eindeutig am meisten
rot, gefolgt von Vodafone und der Rest hier bei O2 ist halt LTE, wobei man ganz ehrlich
sagen muss, reicht ja auch, so, aber jetzt machen wir mal was interessanteres, hier gehe
ich manchmal wandern, ah, das sieht doch schon mal ganz spannend aus hier, ja, hier so, das
ist die Ecke, wo ich ganz gerne mal wandern gehe, lass mal kurz gucken, Hessen, Hessen
in Niedersteinbach, ja oder so, so hier so in der Ecke, da gehe ich ganz gerne wandern,
das heißt, hier haben wir volle Pulle, volle Pulle LTE, Telekom hat 5G und 5G DSS und Vodafone
hat 2, guck mal da, da ist Vodafone zum Beispiel schlechter in dem Fall als die hier, die haben
komplett LTE überall, interessant, gibt es denn irgendwo was, wo gar nicht richtig abgedeckt
ist, so irgendwo im Osten oder so, also ich finde, man sieht schon, dass hier am meisten
blau ist, bei der Telekom ist fast alles mindestens mal lila und bei Telefone ist schon einiges
mehr blau, ah, gucken wir mal hier, so am Arsch der Welt, am Arsch der Welt, irgendwo so
irgendwo, ja, groß, groß, muckro, alles klar, was gibt es denn da, ok, sogar der Telekom
5G, aber im Ernst, so schlimm sieht es doch jetzt gar nicht aus, also für mich sieht
das so aus, dass eigentlich egal, mit welchem Anbieter, man in der Regel eigentlich immer
mindestens 4G hat, bis auf kleinere Flecken, na gut, wenn du halt wirklich hier so am Arsch
der Welt bist, dann hast du teilweise auch gar nichts, Telekom Vodafone haben wir abgedeckt,
nur halt nicht im Zug, das stimmt, also ich fahre hier nach Frankfurt, so hier ist quasi
die Strecke, irgendwo wo ist denn hier der Hauptbahnhof, hier, Hanau, hier, ich fahre
quasi hier lang, durch Meintal, wo ist Meintal Ost, Meintal Ost, findet man nicht, nee,
Meintal Ost, hier habe ich manchmal keine gescheite Verbindung, wobei hier angeblich
alles abgedeckt ist, ok, naja, also hier Meintal Ost habe ich immer morgens, reiße immer
die Verbindung ab für so ein paar Minuten, wenn ich da mit dem Zug durchfahre, also ganz
im Ernst, ich glaube man kann auch O2 verwenden, ja ich sehe es so wie ihr, wenn man hier guckt,
die Telekom finde ich kann man schon so im Großen und Ganzen sagen, ist am besten gefolgt
von Vodafone, man sieht ja auch, das ist halt viel viel mehr blau, aber solange ich LTE
irgendwo habe, soll mir das Recht sein, vor allem wenn ich irgendwie nur die Hälfte
oder so bezahlen muss, das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken, wie sieht es eigentlich
in der Nordsee aus, guck mal in der Nordsee, was ist das, ach das sind irgendwelche Inseln,
guck mal die Inseln sind abgedeckt, der Rest nicht, also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel hier
auf dieser kleinen vorgelagene Insel vor Spiegerrug bin, dann habe ich keinen Mobile Empfang,
Anzeige ist raus, interessant, was kommt denn hier oben drüber Leute, Dänemark, nee, Leute
ich kenne mich geografisch nicht aus, was kommt hier oben drüber, ist das dann schon
Niederlande oder Dänemark, ich weiß es wirklich nicht, keine Ahnung, Dänemark, okay, Niederlande
ist mehr links, nee links ist Frankreich, hier ist doch Frankreich oder, hier ist Dänemark,
nicht, wieso oder stimmt doch, dass Frankreich links ist, Frankreich ist rechts wirklich,
Sekunde, Sekunde, was suche ich denn hier, Google Earth machen wir jetzt auf, okay, wo
sucht man hier was, Frankfurt am Main, da ist Frankreich, was labert ihr denn, natürlich
ist Frankreich links, wer hat erzählt, dass Frankreich auf der rechten Seite ist, chat,
wer hat hier schon wieder so getan, als wisst ihr es besser, selbstverständlich ist Frankreich
links von Deutschland, wer was, chat, wer hat hier wieder Mist erzählt, der Lars hat
wieder so getan, Frankreich, nein ist es nicht, wieso alle so tun, als stimmt das nicht, was
ich gesagt habe, guck hier, da sind wir und Frankreich ist links von uns oder westlich
von uns, westlich von uns, könnte man auch sagen, okay hier oben ist Dänemark, wie sind
wir jetzt eigentlich da drauf gekommen wieder, ihr Dieterlande sind da, Polen ist da, okay
alles klar, hier und übrigens Leute wisst ihr eigentlich, dass ich hier wohne, in Andorra,
irgendwo hier, wo immer genau überhaupt Andorra, Andorra, ne, das nicht, zumindest ich wohne
auf Twitter in Andorra, allerdings in den Pyreneen das, laut Twitter, ist das das hier,
ist das in den Pyreneen das, ja genau, hier, auf Twitter wohne ich hier und der Grund,
warum ich auf Twitter hier wohne ist, einzig und allein, weil ich die deutschen Trends
auf Twitter nicht aushalte, da ist nichts, da ist gar nichts, ja, aber deswegen ist da
auch ruhig, da ist auf Twitter, einmal im Jahr, einmal im Jahr trendet auf Andorra,
wenn die Tour de France hier langfährt, gibt es einmal im Jahr einen Trend auf Twitter Andorra,
irgendwie Le Tour, Tour de France und ansonsten nichts, keine Trends auf Andorra, einmal im
Jahr gibt es was, es war, es trendete letztens nochmal irgendwas, als die, als die in Spanien,
da gab es doch so, die Aufstände kann man glaube ich nicht sagen, aber es gab doch vor
zwei drei Jahren in Spanien so, so Bestrebungen, dass manche Teile unabhängig werden wollen
und sowas und ich glaube, da war Andorra auch dabei, das ist da auch getrendet, aber ansonsten
trendete einmal im Jahr die Tour de France und das war's, wobei man sagen muss, ey ohne
Mist, ich war da ja noch nie in Andorra, aber ich muss echt sagen, ich glaube umgebungstechnisch
ist es da wirklich sehr hübsch und man kann sehr schön wandern, wenn man dann gerne Berge
hoch und runter läuft, ja, excellent, was ist das, ein Museum, aber wisst ihr was, es ist
eigentlich mega gute Qualität oder, mittlerweile im Browser, Google Earth, jetzt fehlen mir
bloß noch irgendwelche Flat Earther, die, gab es nicht auch mal Google Sky View oder
sowas, Google Sky Map, gab es nicht auch mal sowas in der Richtung, nicht Street View,
Google Sky, die Webseite sieht schon aus wie 1995, ja, da kann man dann reinscrollen und
fragt man sich, was ist das, ich hab keine Ahnung, nur weil der Chat gesagt hat, dass
Frankreich nicht links von uns ist, wenn man so drauf guckt auf eine Karte, sondern angeblich
rechts von uns, da muss ich nachgucken, das hat, ne das hab ich mir nicht angeschaut,
aber jetzt müssen wir erstmal in die Tarife weitergucken, ich muss irgendwas bestellen,
weil es wird wirklich eng, also ich muss das die nächste Woche muss ich meine Rufnummer
umziehen lassen, ok, das machen wir schon mal nicht, das machen wir auch nicht, so,
lass doch mal hier durchgucken, ob die Seite was taugt, ob man da auch das alles auswählen
kann, Urlaubsreise, Mietwagen, weder noch, Handy, Handy mit Vertrag, Handy Tarif, nur
Simkarte, sehr gut, Vertragslaufzeit ein Monat, sag mal ab 10G, überhaupt, und wo kann ich
jetzt einstellen, kann man da noch irgendwelche Custom Sachen einstellen, so wie ich möchte
Multisim und, ne kann man nicht, ja das ist ja doof, dann bringt mir der Vergleich auch
nicht, ne kann man nicht einstellen, Esem, ne das bringt mir nichts, haben Sie Fragen,
die reichen uns innerhalb einer Minute, ne ne, müssen Sarah jetzt nicht anrufen, Doktor
Sim, ist ein Anbieter von Ihnen, hab ich noch nie was gehört, Doktor Sim, dann lasst
uns doch mal bei O2 gucken, Doktor Sim klingt sehr vertrauenswürdig, ja finde ich auch,
du zahlst 25 Euro für 20GB bei der Telekom, wie machst du das, ich bezahl bei der Telekom
für 20GB 55 Euro, aber nur mit Esem bringt mir doch nichts, achso Yang Tarif, da bin
ich zu alt für, oder ich frag den Chainlaw ob der die Sache für mich abschließt, der
ist noch Yang genug und kann das machen, so, Klarmobil, ich möchte meine Rufnummer mitnehmen
korrekt, ok Telekom, yep, denied, gibt's erst gar nicht, guck mal was O2 zu bieten hat,
Mobilfunk, Handys mit Vertrag, Handytarife, was haben wir denn hier, O2 Kunde, nein unter
29, nein über 60, nein Selbstständige, ja aber das ist wahrscheinlich noch teurer,
selbstständiger Tarif kostet 22,49 6G und normal kostet es, ok was bringt es mir dann,
dass ich selbstständig bin, das ist ja noch teurer, ja Leute in 23 Jahren kann ich mir
das dann holen, bald 60 plus, ok gewählte Mindestlaufzeit, no pass, nein, Mindestlaufzeit,
keine Mindestlaufzeit, was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen Mindestlaufzeit
und ohne Mindestlaufzeit, hä, doppeltes Datenvolumen, 3 plus 3, ok, ohne Laufzeit 6, ich weiß nicht
ob das denen nicht klar ist, aber 6 ist das gleiche wie 3 plus 3, Quickmaps, ansonsten
sehe ich da ehrlich gesagt wenig Unterschied, Anschlussgebühr, ne die Anschlussgebühr
ist auch dabei, keine Ahnung was da der Unterschied sein soll, warum ich überhaupt 24 Monate Laufzeit
nehmen sollte, die Augen befeuchten, dazu kann ich nur sagen, man hat einen natürlichen
Augenbefeuchter und das nennt sich Augenlider, die kann man ab und zu zumachen und dann wieder
aufmachen und dann sind die Augen befeuchtet, ich weiß richtig ist Hexenwerk aber das hat
jeder, das kommt quasi per Default, wie kann sowas eigentlich legal sein, stimmt, Moment,
Moment, Moment, die haben Tarife für unter 29 und über 60 und nicht für Leute dazwischen,
also das ist eindeutig dann Age Shaming, oder, ich finde wir sollten die mal Shitstormen
auf Twitter dazu, ja das geht ja gar nicht, das ist Age Shaming, Best Ager Diskriminierung,
wie viele Youtube Tabs ich offen habe, also schätzungsweise 30 plus nochmal 20, ich hab
ganz Youtube auf, kannst ja einen Twitter Trend in Andorra machen, coole Idee, bei Auto musst
du glaube ich in einen Shop gehen, ne das kann ich hier online bestellen, ok, also dann
lass mal kurz gucken, haben die nichts, sag mal was ist denn das schon wieder, 6 Gigabyte,
40 Gigabyte, wie wärs denn zum Beispiel mit 12, anstatt 6, 40, ok die haben 6, 40 Unlimited
oder wie, ne Moment, da gibt es doch 120 und es gibt noch Unlimited, warum ist Unlimited,
ok jetzt wirds verwirrend, warum ist Unlimited billiger als 120G, hab das gesehen, 2Mbps
dafür sollst du auch Geld bezahlen, das ist ja quasi fast das was du bei anderen bekommst
wenn dein Datenvolumen abgelaufen ist, ok wir haben so Unlimited Smart, das kostet das
gleiche wie 120G, da gibt es schon 10Mbps, ja das ist doch Shit oder, ah ok, die wollen
im Prinzip dass du Unlimited unbegrenzt kaufst, also eigentlich kannst du diese 2 Tarife vergessen,
du kannst diese 2 Tarife vergessen, im Prinzip haben die 6, 40, 120 und Unlimited, der Rest
ist irgendwie so ein Zwischending, ich fänds allerdings wirklich ganz cool, ich hab ne Backe
in der Seite gefunden Leute, guck mal, ne jetzt ist wieder, jetzt ist wieder ok, eben stand
120 plus 20 und hier unten stand, ohne Laufzeit weiterhin, na gut, also ok, das ist ja durchaus
in Ordnung eigentlich, also wenn man sich das mal anguckt, 40G, 40G ist halt mehr als
ich brauche, 20 ist ok, eine Multicard kostet bei den 10€ im Monat, ganz schön teuer,
guck mal mal, 02 Multicard, ach nicht Multisim, 2 dazu können wir mitnehmen, ok, ok, ok, ok,
woher weiß man was es kostet, kosten, bei einer Multicard Option fallen bei jeder zusätzlichen
Simkarte Kosten, was kosten Multicard, für die Multicard kann tarifabhängig eine Aktivierungsgebühr
je nach Karte anfangen sowie nach O2 tarifmonatliche Kosten, das sind tarifanalysig, mit O2 connect
können sie unsere Narbis, hä, warum ist das so undurchsichtig, was wollt ihr mit O2 connect,
ist das der Nachfolger von, wo ist Carlos Matos, also mit O2 connect können sie unsere
neuen Tarifmonaten, was ist O2 connect, O2 free connect, ich weiß überhaupt nicht was
die von mir wollen hier, was wollen die überhaupt von mir, ok also, wir probieren das mal aus,
zum Warenkorb, keine Auswahl, die wollen mir nicht allen ernstes erzählen, dass sie
standardmäßig so ein Chat hier ausgewählt haben, weiter ohne Auswahl, und woher weiß
ich jetzt, du sparst insgesamt bei was, bei was spar ich, hä, ein Monat mal 5, stand
in der Tarifübersicht was, ich würd's gern einfach mal zusammengerechnet haben, was
ist, connect Option, nutze, nutze dein Datenvolumen auf allen deinen Geräten ohne, einen extra,
zwei SIM-Karten auf Wunsch, auch als erhältst du automatisch über die gratis, mein O2 abkanzler
oder bekümmler entfällt, also ich würd jetzt fast so sagen, das ist umsonst dabei, Multisim,
ok nice, hier steht ja noch weniger Informationen dazu, also so wie ich das verstehe ist die,
ist die zweite SIM-Karte hier dabei, umsonst, ja, das, das klingt doch eigentlich, klingt
doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll, so heißt im Endeffekt, bei O2 würde ich 29€ im Monat
bezahlen für zwei SIM-Karten und 40GB Volumen, die unterstützen eSIM und bis zu, keine Ahnung,
bis zu 10 SIM-Karten oder so, das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht, finde, das ist durchaus
interessante Kondition, ja, wenn es dann auch wirklich so ist, wie man das jetzt denkt,
du kannst da noch 25€ draus machen, echt, wie denn, high fat, nur mit der connect Option,
aber die sind doch dabei, guck, Produkt Details, Connect Option, die ist dabei, zwei Zusatz-E-SIMs
mit Telefonie plus Karten nur mit Datenvolumen, ja, das ist doch wunderbar, Moment, Zweitvertrag
für 10€, dann ist der Hauptvertrag 50% günstiger, Moment, wenn ich zwei Verträge abschließe
heißt es, es ist unterm Strich billiger, was, wie jetzt, Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal
prüfen, also du meinst, wenn ich jetzt noch den billigsten Tarif nehme, Moment, der billigste
kostet ja schon 20€, da blickt doch keiner mehr durch, nee, ok, das juckt, das juckt
den auf jeden Fall nicht, oder, Moment, vielleicht muss ich danach was anderem gucken, vielleicht
muss ich danach Kombiangeboten gucken, Zweit- und Partnerkarte, vielleicht sowas in der
Richtung, das ist mega undurchsichtig alles, O2-3S-Boost, ah, yes, Pre-Pairing, ja, ja,
ah, yes, Pre-Paid, was haben wir da, 50% Rabatt, Volles Datenvolumen zum halben Preis,
und da kostet 20 euro warum gibt es jetzt seriously warum gibt es warum gibt es nicht
einfach das hier in dem anderen und und mit 5g das wäre doch optimal für mich das sind
ok 12 12 ist ein bisschen wenig ach scheiß drauf also ich finde das ding hier gar nicht
mal so übel ehrlich gesagt gucken was sie mir sagen das finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht
19 euro moment das ist ich habe doch den anderen meine güte alter was sind seite das hier meine
ich das da keine auswahl weiter wunderbar ok 30 30 euro im monat es gibt multiple sims
e sims und alles mögliche das ist doch gut das kann man doch kann man doch nehmen theoretisch
können ich das vielleicht wirklich für meine mutter noch was abschließen wie sieht es mit
reinen datentarifen aus wäre das günstige reine datentarife will ich nicht ich muss ja da ab und
zu auch mal drüber telefonieren also wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sagen würde hey meine mutter
nimmt das auch wobei nö das ist immer noch teurer als ihren aldi talk also lohnt sich nicht
ok dann dann läuft wahrscheinlich auf 30 euro raus 50 prozent auf die ok
zeitmeier priority bis zu 50 prozent rabatt für familie und freunde auf ein
oder datenvertrag warum gibt es seine eigene seite und sie zeigen das nicht bei der anderen
sache mit o2 freude bereiten bitte loggen sie habe keine kautz online im shop oder über die
hotline die neue kaut online unter leute hat jemand in o2 freundes kaut für mich so
für wen gilt das angeboten warte mal also wenn du einen hast nicht im twitch chat posten lieber
im discord oder so also ich muss sagen ich finde das hier gar nicht mal so schlecht dieses diese
diese den tarif den sie gerade gibt wir gucken jetzt noch mal wir gucken jetzt noch mal was
voterfonds zu bieten hat stimmt ja aber ich weiß immer noch nicht ob ich dazu ein video machen
will mir fällt nichts gescheites ein so telekom haben wir schon geguckt das heißt jetzt wird
zeit für die hier was haben die dann zu bieten mobilfunk finde deinen mobilfunk angebot chat
ich bin ja bei voterfonds ja ich habe ja mein normales zeug auch bei voterfonds da könnte das
vielleicht sogar billiger sein die sache ist nur die wie verhält sich das dann wenn ich mein
normales internet zeug bei voterfonds kündige und mein handy dort weiter behalten will dann
dann wird es teurer vertrag ohne smartphone angebot für alle selbstständigen ist das billig ich
habe internet und festnetz bisschen billiger ok also die haben giga chat mobile da sind wir
schon bei 34 euro für unbegrenzt wie jetzt das das ist das das ist das das glaube ich euch nicht
zehn prozent rabatt für selbstständige
du solltest bei der rufnummern portierung darauf achten ob du die rufe immer innerhalb des gleichen
netzanbieters überhaupt mitnehmen kannst du meinst wenn ich von von der telekom zur telekom
gehe dass das kann doch immer sein seine telefonnummer mitnehmen ach nee du meinst wenn ich von telekom
zu telekom gehe dass dieser hell jetzt wie du wechselst doch gar nicht also meine arbeit hat
den vertrag aktuell bei der telekom das ist das dass das unbegrenzt ist richt richtig
richtig süß vertrag ohne smartphone
schau mal speed wo sieht man das 5g
tarif details unbegrenzt datenvolumen
widerspricht sich das jetzt nicht irgendwie leute widerspricht sich 30g durchgestrichen
unbegrenzt nicht etwa hier mit 30g ich sag doch das ist extrem sass wieder was da läuft
unbegrenzt heißt bei denen schlicht und ergreifend die schalten mich nicht ab aber kein anbieter
schaltet mich mehr ab sondern du wirst halt gedrosselt ja geil
giga kombi was wohl die gehen wir schon wieder so offen sagt man kann es nicht einfach offensichtlich
sein was man bekommt dafür und gut ist ich will auch gar nichts kombinieren ich will
einfach ein handy vertrag haben giga mobile m l red m red l giga xl red xs yang plus l plus minus l plus xsl 2019 was ist
bei euch verkehrt wey zu tank war das gerade deutsch rap ne da hätte ich noch erzählen
müssen dass ich die bitches ficke oder sowas ohne geht das bei deutsch rap nicht was ich
aber schon mal sehr interessant finde leute ist ach ja wisst ihr was ich sehr interessant
finde dass das angebot für selbstständige günstiger ist
hier ist wirklich unbegrenzt ok also dass das für selbstständige günstiger ist als
für nicht selbstständige oder ist das eine inklusive steuern und das andere nicht inklusive
steuern am moment mindestvertragslaufzeit war bei einem wie kann ich den mindest
mindestvertragslaufzeit ich will keine 24 monate mindestvertragslaufzeit geht mir mit dem scheiß weg man ok
probieren wir das mal alle preise inklusive mehrwertsteuer ja ich will aber meine firma ist im
handelsregister eingetragen ich bin ihk mitglied bin ich dann im handelsregister eingeladen oder
ist das was was ich hätte extra machen müssen also ich habe kein extra handelsregister eintrag
irgendwie meines wissens nach machen lassen ne ok ja das habe ich das habe ich ja nachweisen kann
ich das ich habe ja ich habe ja noch den wie ist das amt keine ahnung die bestätigung von
dem amt wo ich damals gewesen bin du hast einen code lass uns jetzt mal nachher im discord
ausprobieren falls du im discord bist jetzt nicht jetzt nicht oder du kannst mir das doch
daku ich weiß wie wir es machen ich schreibe dich mal kurz an über twitch die die twitch
über die twitch chat funktion das ist quasi private message über twitch danke ich probiere
das nachher mal aus mit mit code wäre das natürlich konkurrenzlos billig extremely extremely
pogu dann kaufe ich mir einfach was mit mit geschnortem gutschein code aus dem chat das
da was da habe ich wenigstens was von da ist exquisite warte lieber auf black friday ich
kann nicht warten ich habe noch zwei wochen zeit mir neuen vertrag zu suchen was natürlich
richtig billig ist leute wenn man wurde von kunde ist unselbstständig guckt mal moment
unbegrenzt gibt es gar nicht für wenn du wurde von kunde bist darfst du nicht unbegrenzt
machen wie viele wie viel datenvolumen brauchst du stimmlich brauchst du gar nur weniger
oder verkehrt ja das reicht also ich hatte ich habe gesagt so um die 20 ne es ist inklusive
mehrwertsteuer steht da es ist inklusive mehrwertsteuer das muss ich mir tatsächlich noch mal angucken
so so blöd so blöd finde ich die idee gar nicht das bei voterfonds zu holen ok also
ich meine selbstständig den nachweis kann ich den schicken also habe ich jetzt zur auswahl
also ich hätte einmal also ob ganz ehrlich für mich ist jetzt der unterschied 21 gig
oder 15 was wollen die eigentlich warum steht hier 15 wenn es doch wenn es doch 21 ist
kann mir mal jemand erklären warum muss das so unglaublich shady und undurchsichtig
sein alles immer warum kann da nicht einfach stehen ohne sternchen ohne irgendeinen scheiß
einfach das das das das kostet am ende das fertig für mich haben die das erhöhnt die
sind aber die sind aber so nett dass sie es für mich erhöhnen die sind so nett dass
sie es für mich erhöhnen so dass sie es nicht reinschreiben ach komm mal man kann
auch wait a minute was ist das denn jetzt schon warum kostet es nee das ist doch genau das
gleiche
internet
was internet und telefonie ja gut mobilfunk internet und telefonie ja ok aber ich ich
finde es ich finde es extrem extrem unsichtig also an sich noch bei einem anderen mobilanfieter
jetzt ist ja auf geht's auch noch spar stellst dann bekommst du für die laufzeit als albermann
nee quatsch nee ok das funktioniert nicht ok also das finde ich das finde ich nicht
schlecht ja so sieht es aus die telekom hat die beste abdeckung ganz ehrlich ich finde
noch das wie es die telekom beschrieben hat noch am da blickt man noch am besten durch
es ist zwar teuer es ist eigentlich viel viel zu teuer muss ich ehrlich sagen ich mein
nehmen wir mal das hier 45 euro im monat ach zusatz sind bei vodafone genau gut dass ihr
das sagt leute vodafone e sim das wird es doch geben oder e sim bestellen multisim
kann die einfach was hinschreiben die vodafone und die multisim kostet hier extra anscheinend
würde ich jetzt mal my deals übersichten gecheckt nee oder vorn heißt es multikart
oder multisim ja multisim kosten multisim war im wahrenkorb wirklich e sim war im wahren
korb warum ist es jetzt auf einmal so teuer das ist doch überhaupt nicht das was ich
angeklickt habe angebot für selbstständige 21 da ich will nicht sparen aber das ist
richtig so ok in den wahren korb nutzt du deinen internetanschluss in enemy ja über
welche bekommst du dein internet kabel das ist absolut das ist doch wahnsinn mann warum
wie kompliziert kann man es eigentlich machen jetzt sind wir schon mal 35 euro da lohnt sich
es wieder nicht leute ohne scheiß glaube ich nehme echt o2 easy ruft dort an nö kein
bock also ohne scheiß wenn das mit dem qr code funktionieren sollte mein was mein handy
.de klingt auch bisschen shady oder machen wir gar nicht auf ach jetzt ist es auf einmal
dein handy.de ok das gibt es wirklich das ist aber weit das ist aber einer von diesen
weiteren 08 15 anbieter klonen wo es total total viele gibt ich glaube ach so das ist
moment das ist gar kein anbieter das ist ein vergleichsportal oder sowas in der richtung
oder ein reseller aber man kann ja auch nicht multisim und so auswählen ok leute scheiß
drauf ich glaube ohne mist ich tendiere tatsächlich aktuell schlicht angreifen hierzu da blickt
man noch halbwegs durch nicht im stream öffnen nein ich öffne das noch nicht im stream ich
gucke mir das nachher an ja ja ich weiß ich gucke das nachher an ich mache das jetzt hier
nicht auf so also wenn das klappt ja bis zu 50 prozent angeblich wobei ich das erst glaube
wenn ich wenn ich sehe ja läuft ein kabel internetanschluss stabil habe gehört da soll
das problem mit geschwindigkeiten geben bei war davon gibt es immer wieder probleme ich
würde eigentlich fast dazu übergehen sage es gibt bei jedem internetanbieter immer wieder
probleme allerdings bei war davon doch relativ häufig ich muss aber sagen sie haben es die
letzten paar monate fast schon das letzte jahr über relativ gut hinbekommen also ich
glaube ich hatte das letzte jahr über nur zwei drei tage mal probleme wo ich auch nicht
gescheit streamen konnte das ist zwar immer noch viel zu viel und ich glaube mittlerweile
auch dass wurde von mich auf irgendeine influencer streamer liste gesetzt hat weil ich letztens
per pn von wurde also letztens vor einem jahr oder so als ich das letzte mal mit dem voter
von support geschrieben habe habe ich auf einmal keine nachricht vom support bekommen
sondern von irgendeinem komischen
ich sehe jetzt gar nicht warum ich denn also das letzte mal das letzte das letzte mal
wo ich mich beschwert habe bei wurde davon dass irgendwas nicht ging ist schon ein bisschen
her das war schon ich sehe schon das ist tatsächlich schon ein bisschen länger her
zumindest hat dann irgendwie so ein random random typ geschrieben der nicht vom support
war dass ich mich bei ihm melden soll wegen rückerstattung und sonst was also ich habe
anscheinend zu sehr rumgeflämt immer öffentlich über vote auf vorn also vielleicht stehe
ich bei denen auf irgendeiner streamer influencer liste drauf oder so nicht desto trotz gibt
es immer immer wieder probleme und ansonsten muss ich sagen funktioniert ganz gut als es
besser als was die telekom bei mir zu bieten hat weil bei mir gibt es aktuell von der telekom
nur dsl beziehungsweise vdsl und vdsl hat man zwar im hinterkopf immer noch so als
super krasse schnelles zeug aber im jahr 2000 2023 ist vdsl hat auch nicht mehr super krasse
schnelles zeug also insofern kopfer keg alu es wird mal echt langsam zeit für glasfaser
ich bin der erste in der straße der mir das in keller legen lässt wenn die am start sind
ja also leute ich vermute alte rufnummer mitnehmen da steht auch noch was dazu ich vermute mal
dass es tatsächlich auf o2 raus laufen wird ich finde die kombination ganz gut wenn das
mit dem gutschein code geht noch viel viel besser
alte rufnummer einfach mitnehmen die beauftragung der portierung geht einfach schnell auf der
folgenden seite alternativ können sie dies auch aktivierung in das vertrag in ihrem online
kundenkonto beauftragen ok ja das werde ich dann machen also ich glaube ich glaube weitere
hinweise und fußnoten ah yes zum tarif hier steht es doch zum tarif können bis zu zwei
weitere multi karts plus sieben data karts zu gebucht werden die jeweils auf das im tarif
halte high speed datenvolumen zugreifen bei den zugritte ja ok was was wollen die sonst
doch o2 3m booster flex keine mindestvertragslaufzeit ja das ist gut 40 gb datenvolumen nach verbrauch
des enthaltenen datenvolumens ja das mit 40 g komm ich locker hin
das klingt doch eigentlich ganz sinnvoll ich glaube ich glaube das werde ich werde ich
nehmen 30 euro vielleicht mit dem mit dem gutschein code noch anderweitig ja ich glaube
da gucke ich nicht weiter das ist ganz gut so das werde ich bestellen auf stream ich trage
jetzt hier nicht meine daten ein und den gutschein code und dann hoffe ich dass es dann ankommt
und ich die rufnummernportierungen beauftragen kann excellent wunderbar hätten wir das auch
schon was machen wir denn jetzt leute erst eineinhalb stunden oder ein stunde eine fast eine stunde
45 und was machen wir denn jetzt noch so eine halbe stunde irgendwas machen können wir doch
gibt es gibt es irgendwas gibt es irgendwas spannendes noch worüber wir unbedingt reden
müssen javascript noch heute heute kein javascript ich kann euch übrigens noch was erzählen ich
kann euch etwas von der arbeit erzählen und zwar also ich bin ja ich bin ja ende des monats
weg und kollege von mir ist auch ende des monats weg so und jetzt kommt jetzt kommt
der hit wüsste das wüsste euch mal auf der zunge zergehen lassen der ist ja auch schon
monate wenn ich jahrelang dort am nerven mit bessere homeoffice regelungen mehr geld und
sowas und sie sagen ja seit jahren immer so ist es ganz schlecht so als war es korona
jetzt ist in jetzt ist hier inflationen so hoch und das geschäft ja ganz schlimm und
sie reden sich immer raus so jetzt kommt jetzt kommt der hammer pass mal auf also wir hauen
beide ende des ende des monats ab so und jetzt haben sie ihn gefragt ob er denn nicht bei
irgendeinem plan mitmachen will so wie könnte man x y z verbessern hat er gesagt ja normalerweise
hätte ich da gerne mitgemacht also da geht da geht es um irgendwie so so konzept erstellen
so weil er sich mit dem thema gut auskennt und ob er da was zu sagen kann normalerweise
würde ich mitmachen aber ich bin am 30 dritten nicht mehr in der firma tätig so und jetzt
habe ich gehört hat haben die allen ernst zu überlegt ob sie ihn nicht wieder einkaufen
sollen für 7 8 stunden die woche allerdings dann hat er gemeint dann nur für ja externes
gehalt also 80 euro die stunde wenn die das machen würden wir so unglaublich bescheuert
mann erst sind sie so knauserig erst sind sie so knauserig ja und sagen wie was wie
mehr home office nee gibt es nicht aber was wie mehr geld oh nee gibt es nicht ok dann
kündige ich ja machs gut tschüss achso wie können ich auch für 80 euro die stunde
noch mal einkaufen für 8 stunden die woche seid ihr bescheuert 80 euro die stunde in
frankfurt das ist aber arg wenig was ist denn gut in frankfurt keine ahnung weiß ich was
man da so sagen sollte da muss ja noch dementsprechend versteuert werden und alles
hat hier jemand best skripte zu python überführt wie schwer könnte es werden es geht darum
zieht uns bildtest upload nach nexus oh ein java entwickler oder ich persönlich bevorzuge
ja java ok leider können wenige im team shell scripting das dürfte nicht sonderlich schwierig
sein also wahrscheinlich ist es hier also je nachdem was ihr macht können ich mir vorstellen
dass es in python sogar ein bisschen einfacher ist das ganze zu machen weil wenn ihr irgendwelche
anderen tools anspricht gibt es für die wahrscheinlich schon fix und fertige python packages dann
müsst ihr gar nicht irgendwelche best befehle aufrufen und die rum palmen und crepten dazwischen
sondern könnte die jeweiligen tools direkt über ihre python packages wie nennt sich
das bei python eigentlich bei ruby sind es gems bei ross sind es kreates wie heißt es
denn bei python ist glaube ich einfach nur packages oder packages modules nee ich glaube
packages oder jetzt ist hip packages ja ist das offiziell packages heißt es also ich glaube
nicht dass es schwierig ist umzustellen je nachdem was jeder macht könnte es sogar einfacher
sein in python nee nee artefacts heißt nicht python packages also mal angenommen ihr macht
in euren scripts also gehen wir jetzt mal gehen wir jetzt mal davon aus was weiß ich ihr wollt
irgendwie was weiß ich habt ihr in den push script was dann in den jenkins job anwirft
und irgendwelche sachen pusht irgendwo sonst wohin da könnte es ja durchaus sein dass es
einfacher ist das in python zu machen weil ihr dann das offizielle jenkins python package
verwenden könnt das offizielle nexus python also nexus api python packages package verwenden
können dass es sogar einfacher ist das in python zu machen als in bash dass es einfacher ist und
vielleicht sogar besser funktioniert nee da würde ich mir wenig gedanken darüber machen ich
persönlich mag bash skripte schon wenn es halt sachen verwenden die schon da sind ja wo man
relativ einfach mit den vorhandenen tools was bauen kann zum beispiel zum beispiel ich habe
im für solche sachen finde ich das was will er denn units das ist kein bug ich glaube
er versteht ich glaube er versteht die den output falsch das ist der output wie sein
home assistant eingestellt ist sein home assistant ist auf zelsius und kilometer eingestellt die
werte selbst kommen in miles konvertiert wenn er diese option macht egal was ich jetzt eigentlich
sagen wollte ich habe so ein mini mini minist build skript für sachen die ich immer vergesse ja ich
gruppiere die ritme in die richtige datei ich und ich hole mir den version stack raus so fertig also
für sowas finde ich best sinnvoll das ist jetzt für sich ganz ganz kleine variante für so sachen
die man jedes mal wieder neu tippen müsste dafür finde ich so best natürlich besser besser
geeignet ist als jede andere sprache das macht in keiner sprache so einfach wie in best sowas hier
aber wenn man größere sachen machen will ist es wahrscheinlich sogar einfacher das in python zu
machen und wenn es dafür offizielle packages gibt noch noch noch besser gelabert jetzt also
100 und ohne unter 100 euro auf keinen fall sagst du mit vermittler dazwischen oder nicht
sehen wir def in frankfurt als kann es schon dreistellig gehen ja ich habe jetzt einfach
noch irgendwas gesagt vielleicht sollten wir sogar noch mehr sagen ich fragte einfach mal ob
ich nicht auch noch ein paar stunden die woche zusätzlich was machen soll ich habe montags viel
zeit einfach jeden monat noch mal jeden montag vier stunden 400 euro beim wobei ohne scheiß
leute das würde ich nicht machen wisst ihr warum ich das nicht machen würde der grund warum ich
teilzeit arbeite ist ja weil mir die kohle reicht und ich mehr zeit haben will hier für streaming
youtube und andere sachen die mich interessieren und ich bin mittlerweile auf dem gehalsniveau
angelangt ich denke da kann man ohne probleme sagen man kommt damit gut aus und mehr ist zwar
immer nice aber muss auch nicht notwendigerweise sein also dann habe ich lieber mehr freizeit
schreibt aber bei mir lief es genauso max einsatzbereitschaft sollte ich zeigen bei
schon 60 moment so viel darf man doch gar nicht oder ist nicht bei 48 oder so die woche
schluss aber mehr geld sollte es nicht geben gekündigt nicht mal zweimal nachdem ich nicht
mehr da war gab es ja verkaufen nicht ein ja beste beste ist doch gut für dich
ja die normalen it dienstleister wenn du zu irgend zu irgendeiner programmierer entwickler
bude gehst was die dann abrechnet aber es geht ja hier um den einzelnen typ keine ahnung ich
muss mich da mal schlau machen es geht nicht um mich es geht überhaupt nicht um mich das
falsche mindset fack leute ich gebe es zu ich habe nicht das high performer mindset wird nicht
genug gehaschelt und so kommen wir auch nicht auf den mount everest aber kann ich aber mit
leben dafür mache ich was sinnvolles in meiner zeit außer andere leute zu scammen und den zu
erzählen wie sie erfolgreich werden und erfolgreich werden heißt kein sinnvolles geschäftsmodell
haben sondern den ursprünglichen erfinder reich machen und nicht die leute selbst dafür mache
ich was sinnvolles mit meiner zeit und erzählen nicht irgendwie scam nicht irgendwelche leute
es geht ohne das high performer mindset ich bin gespannt ich bin mal gespannt ob die das
ob die das ihm anbieten so nach dem motto wir kaufen mich ein das wäre auf jeden fall
witzig mein mein auge mann das ist das bestimmt oh to reseller hier das das sieht sehr ähnlich
aus so das sollte ich mir mal angucken hat letztens jemand im chat geschrieben was ist
das 30 dollar usb switch into full featured kvm also so ein so ein umschaltding für tastaturen
was heißt das überhaupt keyboard video ne was heißt denn kvm überhaupt keyboard ich weiß
gar nicht für was kvm steht switch für was für was steht kvm überhaupt video mouse keyboard
video mouse da hätte auch selbst drauf kommen können das turns a simple usb switch into
a full flashed kvm solution press one button on your usb switch in allem und wie soll das
jetzt funktionieren oah auge geblendet ok usb ja usb switch
ok und jetzt ach so moment der hat die monitore schon an den geräten angeschlossen und da
schaltet er nur den monitor input oder das ist doch das hat aber mit kvm über netzwerk
nix wirklich zu tun oder sehe ich das sehe ich das jetzt falsch
es ist doch gbade ja ja das ok das das bringt ja dann das bringt ja dann wirklich was das
ist das ist cool wenn man zwei monitoren wenn man hier zwei rechner hat die man unabhängig
voneinander benutzen will und dann die tastatur da drüber umschalten will sowas ja ok aber
richtigen kvm ersatz ist es nicht weil eine richtig gute kvm und das der richtige vorteil
von vom kvm ist ja auch wenn die netzwerk fähig sind dass du zum beispiel an server
gehen kannst der gar nichts mehr macht und dann dann dort übers netzwerk drauf zugreifen
kannst ansonsten ist das ja eher so convenience auf dem schreibtisch hier moin patrick danke
für den sub 44 monate massive subscription pkvm wisst ihr was leute oder man geht zu ebay
und kauft sich ein ich habe vergessen wie diese dinge heißen ne ne ne ne ne pkvm connect
irgendwas tronik oder so ist der kram ne wie ist das ding was ich mir gekauft habe hier
landtronix landtronix spider die hat 70 euro oder so gekostet damals bei ebay habe ich
sofort zugeschleim gab es bei im dutzen billiger was was was warum ist das so alter was ist
denn mit euch los 270 euro versandt kannst damit auch sender machen ja klar kannst du
schließt das an per vga schließt das an per vga und usb und dann kommste kommste so kannst
auch ins bios und alles krass alter ja man na na pkvm ist raspberry pi aktuell zu kriegen
ist auch keine ich hätte jetzt gesagt wenn 70 euro kostet ist man gut dabei weil man
hat eine fertig funktionierende lösung alter warum ist das denn so unglaublich teuer man
mittlerweile da fack und warum kosten rechner von 1995 so viel warum was ist mit ihnen los
warum ist warum ist das so teuer das teil
ne das ist gar kein rechner oder das ist ein cd brenner ne oder was was was ist das
überhaupt ein print server warum nicht einfach im netzen steht normaler netzwerk drucker
gut wahrscheinlich für super high performance printing also dass die dinger so teuer sind
mittlerweile ist mega heftig wie gesagt ich habe ich habe dafür 70 euro oder so was in
dem dreh bezahlt
na gut bei ebay klein anzeigen kann ich ja nicht mehr kaufen weil die mich ja gebannt
haben
du hattest glück das kann sein allerdings zu dem zeitpunkt wo ich das gekauft habe gab
es ganz viele auf ebay dazu so in diesem dreh das ist jetzt nix also hätte ich jetzt gedacht
oh krass super schnäppchen gemacht hätte ich es wahrscheinlich auch anders erzählt
was ich was ich gemacht habe bei ebay klein anzeigen ich hatte nie einen account bei ebay
klein anzeigen und ich wollte dann einen account bei ebay klein anzeigen anlegen und da stand
dann sinngemäß irgendwie sowas wie dass ich also als ich dann die e-mail adresse eingegeben
habe stand also ich wollte einen account anlegen da hat es irgendwie gesagt es gebe für diese
e-mail adresse schon was und dann wollte ich die e-mail adresse eingeben und dann haben
sie gesagt ich wurde gebannt ich hatte nie einen account ich habe nie ebay klein anzeigen
benutzt und dann habe ich an den support geschrieben von ebay klein anzeigen und da haben die gar
nichts sinnvolles geantwortet sondern nur geschrieben bitte bleiben sie unseren marktplatz
fern ich habe es nie benutzt für nichts also das höchste der gefühle ist dass ich irgendwann
mal gesagt habe ich will den account anlegen und diesen account setup prozess nie completed
habe das das kann durchaus sein dass ich mich da mal quasi in so eine invite e-mail hab schicken
lassen und dann nicht das nie abgeschlossen habe dass das kann sein dass es da schon was
gab aber ich habe es nie benutzt ja das kann man machen aber das sehe ich nicht ein also
wer mir so eine dreiste arsch antwort schickt ohne da irgendwie darauf einzugehen dem seine
plattform verwende ich auch nicht ich kann jetzt moment leute ich gucke mal kurz bei
ebay ich hoffe ich kann mich bei ebay noch einloggen hallo max ab sofort verkaufst du
kostenlos ok mein ebay jetzt muss ich mich doch mit dem password einloggen ok oder habe
ich damals sogar bei amazon gekauft kaufübersicht hier kaufübersicht kaufe lantronix steht
nicht drinnen weil weil es älter als sechs monate ist oder kann das sein dass das raus
fliegt aus ebay wenn es älter als sechs monate ist ich gucke mal ich gucke mal in
meinen ich gucke mal in meinen e-mails falls ebay auf diese e-mail adresse geht oh hetzter
hat meine rechnung geschickt was das lol hetzter rechnung hetzter rechnung vom letzten
monat huge 4 cent jetzt wirds aber eng lantronix kaufbestätigung ebay 2019 habe ich das gekauft
kaufbestätigung vielen dank für den kauf 79 99 sage ich doch habe ich bezahlt dafür
ich habe so ein gerät gekauft kann sogar noch die steht sogar noch die die die die
artikelnummer drinne wer bezahlt eigentlich archiv.wupplos.tv das bezahlt das series max
und ich habe mich aber auch daran beteiligt wir bezahlen das aktuell zusammen wobei ich
glaube das aktuelle ja das habe ich nicht das aktuelle ja sogar bezahlt im voraus war
das nicht irgendwie oder war das für was anderes ich weiß es gar nicht genau du hast
deinen ersten github sponsor bekommen nice für dein wacom lanprojekt oder für was
also wie gesagt leute dieses ding habe ich bestellt 79 euro ein euro von dem creator
von noted.loll dazu ist ja quasi das schwimmst du jetzt ja im geld ich hatte mal irgendwie
so eine geld animation aber hier doch also interessant dass es die dinger jetzt nur
für 500 plus gibt nicht sie für 79 euro gekauft hat bei ebay alles klar nice gg eats und wisst
ihr was was mich auch extrem beeindruckt hat bei den dinger aber wirklich massiv kann
soll ich noch mal zeigen archiv kvm
ja oder geiles game müsste ich auch mal wieder spielen mega gem dark messiah of my magic
das war richtig geiles game so gibt es mal ein wenig hintergrundwissen zur technologie
von archiv.voklo.tv du kannst es auf github angucken oder dass sie uns max erzählt da
bestimmt auch was zu wenn du ihn freist ich weiß es ist glaube ich ein vgs frontend und
ein go back end wenn ich jetzt nicht totalen mist erzähle nee ein svelte frontend es ist
ein svelte frontend und ein go back end und dieses ganze postgres ist für die suche glaube
ich postgres ist für die suche und dieses transcribe zeug ist über cloud gpu kisten
mit ai extrahiert worden ist es vgs oder ist es svelte das frontend ja svelte das zeige
ja das ist doch gar nicht so verkehrt was ich gesagt habe ist das vertragsthema schon
abgefrühstückt ja es wird wahrscheinlich auf diesen vertrag hier rauslau wahrscheinlich
läuft es darauf raus vertragstechnisch nee keine angular enjoyers und ernsthaft ich glaube
ich werde auch nie angular enjoyer werden mehr habe ich mir nicht angeguckt aber die
haben wahrscheinlich keine multisim und keine e sim multisim
nee haben sie nicht haben sie nicht ich glaube ich glaube es läuft hier auf raus ja ich brauche
zu mehrere geräte genau nachdem ich keine vertragslaufzeit habe also nur ein monat kann
ich einfach woanders hin wenn es gar so beschissen ist mit dem empfang aber ich denke hier frankfurt
und umgebung wird es schon ganz gut funktionieren was das clean code horrible performance ist
das c++ wenn ich das schon sehe c++ warum habe ich das video offen ich habe das video
offen was ich glaube jetzt weiß ich warum ich das offen habe weil das große wellen
auf hacker news geschlagen hat oder
wollen wir das noch angucken ich glaube das ist kein gutes material für sonntag auf wachens
auf wachens stream kommentare aus das ist wohl standard bei dem ich habe mir andere videos
angeguckt ich dachte auch zuerst dass die hacker news trust task force zu sehr zugeschlagen
hat warum habe ich hier eigentlich nicht moment moment ich brauche doch hier noch dings hier
youtube dislikes add-on return youtube dislikes brauche ich da noch install chrome add extension
aha aha siehst du mal das da sieht man das dislikes doch nicht so unsinnig sind also
was willst du uns sagen okay some of the most often repeated programming advice especially
to beginner programmers is that they should be writing clean code nein nein nein nein
fehlerfreier code dann ist nämlich egal ob er clean ist dann braucht man nie wieder ihn
erst vorher keine fehler programmieren ich sag so oft es kann so einfach sein aber keiner
also ganz ehrlich das unterscheidet sich von sprache zu sprache wie was hübsch aussieht
und ja es gibt sicherlich so ein paar allgemeingültige sachen wie zum beispiel variablen sinnvoll
benennen oder nicht so viel magic alles in line schreiben sondern das auch mal zwischendrin
eine variable zuweisen dass man jetzt weiß was dieser wert bedeuten soll also ja gibt
schon so ein paar allgemeingültige sachen aber es variiert halt auch stark von sprache
zu sprache das ziemlich schlecht aufgelöst für 1080p oder
was geht es jetzt eigentlich genau ok ok er zeigt gleich beispiele was er will
das ist geil dass das finde ich cool mit diesem mit diesem drauf schreiben wie macht er das
denn da schreibt das irgendwo hin und das das ist ja post process drüber glas schreibe
aber leute wenn es eine glas schreibe wäre da könnten wir es doch nicht richtig richtig
lesen da wäre es doch falsch rum oder er spiegelt nachträglich das gesamte video inklusive
ihm selbst aber dann wäre der aufdruck hier falsch oder sein arm wäre auf der falschen
seite das ist gar nicht so einfach wie wir das gemacht also ich gehe davon aus da schreibt
das und dann wird das post processing mäßig nochmal auferlegt oder so
nee leute ich weiß wie er das macht guck mal der schreibt wirklich auf eine tafel man sieht
das hier auch wackeln guck mal der schreibt auf die tafel und der captcha der der captcha
hat irgendwie die tafel und das auferleiter dann weil weil er ist ja auch eindeutig dahinter
hat ein video dazu gemacht echt ok das interessiert das interessiert mich tatsächlich den namen
von ihm mal interessiert mich tatsächlich wie er das gemacht hat
von was spricht er überhaupt das ergibt jetzt überhaupt keinen sinn was ok ich komme überhaupt
nicht was will er was was was was will er uns denn jetzt überhaupt sagen also was ist
an einem if von einem switch statement jetzt ok vielleicht ist es auch gar nicht das was
er uns sagen will aber ich verstehe ich verstehe gar nicht was er mir mitteilen möchte
na gut wenn man das objekt orientiert sieht dann sollte das objekt so gekapselt sein dass
es transparent funktioniert ja ich mein wenn ich wenn ich wenn ich irgendein objekt habe
und das nur mit irgendwelcher reflection magic wo ich um drei ecken raus bekomme wie der
interne state ist ordentlich benutzen kann der typ das erstellt hat irgendwie mist gebaut
oder ok wir kommen wir kommen noch dahinter was er was er will ja da würde ich sagen es
kommt drauf an ja prinzipiell ist es schon sinnvoll wenn es übersichtlich ist aber ich
finde es macht auch keinen sinn also das kann man halt wieder so so pauschal nicht sagen
ich finde es macht aber auch keinen sinn einfach nur damit das eingehalten wird auch bei was
komplexerem alles aufzusplitten nochmal wenn du das aufgesplitterte nur an dieser einen
stelle brauchst also wenn ich jetzt was habe wenn ich ein bisschen komplizierteren sachverhalt
habe so und es sind am ende dann irgendwie 180 zeilen oder sowas ist es halt die frage
wie sinnvoll es ist das aufzusplitten in unterschiedliche funktionen wenn ich die genau nur einmalig
aufrufe also warum sollte ich unter funktionen machen wenn ich die jeweils nur einmal an
der einen stelle aufrufe da kann ich wahrscheinlich auch alles untereinander schreiben und dann
muss jemand der verstehen will wie es funktioniert nicht an 18 verschiedenen stellen gucken also
das hängt halt davon das hängt wirklich ganz entscheidend davon ab was man machen will
es geht darum dass eine funktion einen ding tut ja gut aber das ding kann halt komplex
sein ja was ein ding ist ja eine aufgabe sollte die ist damit gemeint also soll das jetzt
keine funktion haben die zum beispiel irgendwie den input entgegen nimmt diesen input umwandelt
validiert und gleichzeitig hochlädt oder sowas in der richtung sondern du machst eine
validate funktion du machst eine upload funktion und du machst eine input transformation funktion
zum beispiel dann wobei man sich da auch darüber streiten kann ehrlich gesagt wenn die dinger
irgendwie unmittelbar zusammengehören und auch nur an einer stelle gebraucht werden
dann macht es vielleicht doch sinn das in irgendwie so eine so eine du du everything
zu machen wenn ich genau diesen einen fall habe und den nur an dieser einen stelle brauche
und dort eben was als input bekommen dass irgendwie transformieren wird und dann hochladen
will kann man das denke ich durchaus am stück schreiben anstatt dass ich dann irgendwie an
fünf sechs verschiedenen stellen nachgucken muss es kommt drauf an was es ist kann man
so pauschalen gar nicht sagen ich weiß ich mache zu viel pause aber mir fällt immer
dazu ein als ich damals noch viel ruby gemacht habe ruby programmiert habe da habe ich mal
eine konferenz talk gesehen von irgend so einem ruby on rails guru fragt mich nicht mehr wer
das war und ich werde den talk wahrscheinlich auch nicht finden also ihr könnt mich jetzt
glauben oder nicht aber ich habe es ja schon ein paar mal erzählt zumindest hat er in
einem seiner talks erzählt oder hat das das war so eine offene frage so er hat in seinem
talk erzählt so auch und durchsichtige funktionen und solche geschichten hat das publikum gefragt
ja was meint ihr denn ab wann sind für mich funktionen zu lang und das publikum denkt
sich halt so ja alter keine ahnung erzählt uns halt und dann meinte der typ in diesem
talk halt mehr als eine zeile oder dachte ich mir so halt alter wie kompliziert möchtest
du deinen kram bitte schön machen wie kompliziert und und aufgesplittet möchtest du deinen
kram machen wird alles nur nicht länger als eine zeile sein darf er listet gerade clean
code regeln auf ist es eine clean code regel man sollte auf ifs und switches verzichten
ich meine das hier unten macht ja alles so pauschal zwar sinn aber man muss sich immer
im jeweiligen kontext angucken okay
du sollst nicht jetzt verstehe ich was das erste meint du hast recht easy light du sollst
nicht über typen switchen das ist damit gemeint jetzt verstehe ich das also sprich man soll
jetzt nicht objekt bekommen und dann gucken if objekt ist string if objekt ist auto if
objekt ist printer if objekt ist smartphone oder sowas sondern man bekommt ein base objekt
oder was auch immer ein vererbtes objekt wo ich dann das drauf aufrufen kann ohne dass
ich eben explizit den typ checken muss das meint er das meinte das würde ich das würde
ich tatsächlich auch pauschal wieder würde ich sagen ist das eine gute idee es gibt
immer ausnahmen es gibt immer ausnahmen wo es doch sinn macht
c++ muss es ausgerechnet c++ sein
soll ich euch mal was dazu erzählen das ist eine sehr dass das schon seit seit jahrzehnten
eine sehr philosophische debatte darüber geführt wird zum beispiel meine frage an euch
chat ich denke mal viele von euch kennen das mal angenommen bleiben wir mal bei shape
ihr habt eine base class shape so und ihr wollt jetzt eine klasse machen für ellipse
oder sagen wir sagen wir für recht und für quadrat ja oder für kreis oder ellipse leitet
ihr ellipse von kreis ab oder kreis von ellipse oder auch rechteck von quadrat oder quadrat
von rechteck da gibt es schon seit jahrzehnten sehr philosophische debatten drüber
ja ja das das das geht schon in die so so würde ich tatsächlich auch machen so würde
ich so würde ich es auch machen
es ist ja man sieht chat chatte sich da auch nicht ganz einig
das ist das ist ja wobei das halt vererbungstechnik auch schwierig ist also zum beispiel zum
bei also warum es da gibt übrigens also wer das wer das sich im detail angucken will
hier ich hab grad euch mal den wikipedia artikel rausgesucht das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht
zusammen an aber wie gesagt also das problem wird wird schon relativ lange diskutiert und
da gibt es verschiedenste verschiedene lösungsansätze du hast zum beispiel das problem dass du bei
einem rechteck kannst du quasi so die höhe und die breite setzen das macht bei einem
quadrat keinen sinn weil bei einem quadrat ist die höhe und die breite ist immer gleich
das heißt wenn du jetzt ein quadrat ableitest von deiner rechteckklasse kannst du auf einmal
bei deinem quadrat höhe und breite setzen was ja keinen sinn macht oder halt auch hier
aber beim kreis da ist es glaube ich irgendwie durchmesser und sowas in der richtung das
wird seit jahrzehnten schon lange diskutiert es gibt sogar programmiersprachen da ist
tatsächlich so dass rechteck von quadrat abgeleitet ist das meiste sind irgendwelche
super esoterischen dinger wo einer zeigen wollte dass das auch dass das auch geht also
die haben dann rechteck von quadrat abgeleitet weil es aber weil du halt ein aus programmiertechnischer
sicht erweiterst du ja quasi die funktion von einem quadrat so mit dem rechteck nämlich
dass du noch höhe und breite unabhängig voneinersetzen kannst mathematisch gesehen ist es natürlich
bescheuert zu sagen dass jedes rechteck ein quadrat ist das ja das lilux des tops ja das
kommt höchstens mal was wsl also ist sinnvoll einfach oberklasse viereck erstellen viereck
ist dann für dich auch was was kein rechteck ist was auch alles sein kann tja also am besten
ist wahrscheinlich man nimmt shape als base für beides und macht es dann unabhängig
voneinander hier ist das ist ja auch im prinzip gibt es ja hier auch schon die erklärung
zu also was das was das problem ist so was in einer typischen klassenherarschie zur
implementierung der grafik so könnte von einer basisklasse gerade blablabla so die klasse
ellipse abgeleitet werden und von diesen wiederum die krasse die klasse kreis das ist
ja das was ich gesagt habe dass du das das wäre das mathematisch dass du kreis von ellipse
ab ab leitest ach so na ok die beschreiben das hier ein bisschen anders zeichnen ja genau
das ist das ist das beispiel was ich meine ja du kannst du hast jetzt bei ellipse hast
du metoden skaliere x skaliere y das macht aber bei einem kreis keinen sinn weil du kannst
den kreis ja nicht wirklich x skalieren und übs und du kannst es ja immer nur gleich
machen das heißt eigentlich mathematisch gesehen ist es richtig dass kreis von ellipse erbt
allerdings aus objekt orientierter sicht ist es blödsinnig weil er eigentlich ellipse
eine erweiterung von kreis ist also kreis hätte die methode skaliere weil du brauchst
beim kreis skaliere x skaliere y nicht sondern einfach nur scale und dann in beide richtungen
und dann müsstest du logischerweise ellipse von kreis eigentlich ableiten weil dass du
zusätzlich zu skalieren in beide richtungen gleichzeitig unabhängig voneinander skalieren
kannst was dann aber wiederum ein widerspruch ist weil du dann sagen würdest ja ok dass
jede ellipse in kreis ist was auch wieder keinen sinn ergibt das gleiche problem gibt
es auch mit quadrat und rechte genau also wie gesagt da gibt es schon seit jahrzehnten
diskussionen darüber wie es jetzt eigentlich richtig ist und am besten ist finde ich man
umgeht das problem komplett in dem man sowohl kreis als auch ellipse von grafisches element
ableitet also ich vermute dass es wo sind wir denn hier äh warum hat sich das denn jetzt
also da sieht man das geht gar nicht so ohne weiteres alles ja weißt du wann für mich
der code clean ist wenn ich das gefühl habe dass es ein sehr unspezifisches kann man nicht
genau wenn ich ein wenn ich ein gutes gefühl habe wenn ich das durchlese und denke ja das
versteht man gut fertig dann ist clean genug also der fehler der fehler ist schon mal clean
code examples sich in c++ anzugucken weil es ist so ziemlich alles clean plus nicht
z++ base class for a shape and then you have a few shapes that are derived from that base
class circle triangle rectangle square we could add some more if we want to but we have a
virtual function that does something like compute the area and the idea here is we are preferring
polymorphism and for functions to just do one thing and to be small and all that good stuff
you can see that we just have this little tiny area function depending on which of the derived
classes we have we will do a different area computation for the square the rectangle the
triangle or the circle now if we imagine using this if we wanted to find the area of a series
of shapes that we okay aber ich kann der sache immer nicht genau vollen wo jetzt eigentlich
drauf drauf raus will also okay er möchte uns in dem video zeigen dass wenn man es quasi
clean macht dass kack performance ist okay ich finde es ehrlich gesagt in c++ eh schon nicht
mal sondern nicht clean weil ich jetzt überhaupt nicht checken würde wozu gehört dann jetzt zum
beispiel das ist das ist gar kein das ist eine funktion losgelöst von den klassen um okay
ich spule gleich mal ein bisschen vor moment moment moment wenn ich das hier schon sehe da
kommen jetzt gleich wieder die leute aus den löchern und sagen das ist aber nicht modern
c++ das geht nicht das muss ein ein schert pointer auf dingsbums auf shape auf shape base
sein sonst ist ja das ist ja nicht so wirklich das ist sogar ein array oder das müsste ein
schert pointer auf vector auf shape base sein alles klar c++
leute da gehen noch die rustleute auf hacker news bestimmt steil auf so ein video oder
die erzählen uns dann selbstverständlich dass das in rust alles so viel geiler ist
das ist gefundenes fressen für die rust taskforce auf hacker news da gehen die richtig steil drauf
nur dass ich das jetzt ungefähr halbwegs checken was ich da überhaupt sehe ich bin
okay der hat einmal einen benchmark wo diese funktionen einmal ausgeführt werden und dann
wo die 1000 mal ausgeführt werden so dann hat er dann hat eine funktion die irgendwie
alles der reihe nach macht und dann hat er was wo vier stück quasi pro schleifen durchlauf
gemacht werden so in der hoffnung dass das mit cpu inline cashing oder wie auch immer
schneller ist oder oder was ist ja weil es ist ja nicht multithreaded das ganze es ist
passiert halt nur in einer schleife okay
man könnte man könnte auch an der stelle einfach auf ganzen vererbungskram scheißen
und ein interface machen i area oder irgendwie sowas und überhaupt keinen großartigen vererbung
space class stels machen
okay
ehrlich gesagt finde ich dass an der stelle sogar source code technisch sogar noch besser
ließ bei
class of that type now we have effectively the exact same code here's
the switch statement version of the exact spule mal ein bisschen vor
for the vtable version because it doesn't have to wonder about what kind of
types might be derived from a base class it can see everything that's in this
performance between the one that has to use a vtable because it's using C plus
plus classes and one that just can use oh es ist viel schneller
between the two and i'll skip the video here so you don't have to wait for the
testing to happen when we look at the results what you can see is really rather
remarkable just that one change ich muss auch ich muss euch ehrlich sagen das
zweite das zweite beispiel finde ich auch viel einfacher lesbar an der stelle
also ich habe eh den eindruck dass die letzten jahre über es den trend gibt es
nicht mehr so sehr zu übertreiben was objektorientierung angeht selbst in
sprachen wie c sharp die mal ursprünglich als microsoft java abklatsch gestartet
sind die quasi komplett auf objektorientierung gesetzt haben dass
man schon sieht aber javascript diesmal sieht man dass der trend schon ein
bisschen dahin geht wobei javascript macht jetzt tatsächlich das gegenteil
die fangen jetzt mit klasso und tags erst richtig an dass der trend ein bisschen
dahin geht dass man sich so aus der funktionalen ecke bedient dass man dass
man auch teilweise mehr interfaces benutzt dass man mehr anonyme funktionen
als parameter benutzt also zum beispiel dass man jetzt nicht sagt hier array
punkt filter und ich brauche dann irgendwie ein array filter base class
sondern ich mache dann anonyme funktion rein wie gefiltert werden soll
und gut ist und ich bin der trend geht ein bisschen dahin dass es nicht mehr
ganz so schlimm ist die haben es früher ziemlich übertrieben das stimmt aber
mittlerweile sieht man auch dass sie an ganz vielen stellen anstatt jetzt
riesen klas von klas von klas abgeleitet benutzen dass die ganz gerne auch die
dinger kombinieren zusammen mit irgendwelchen bildern und hast du nicht
gesehen also ich finde da sieht man die letzten jahre auch in sie schaab
eigentlich in sie schaab ganz gut weil die letzten sie schaab versionen haben
vieles übernommen was man vorher aus eher funktionalen ecke gekannt hat
ordentliche lambda synthax gibt schon lange seit den letzten paar versionen
wird verstärkt auf so dinger gesetzt wie pattern matching zum beispiel und
solche geschichten das gab es ja früher nicht man kann sich bestimmt
überschreiten
wie schön da manches implementiert ist weil manches finde ich auch nicht gerade
super griffig zu bedienen aber die den einfluss von so
funktionalen sprachen kann man denke ich auch bei sie schaab jetzt nicht mehr
übersehen
die old-fashioned way rather than was hältst du von wpf ehrlich gesagt nix
wpf ist windows only also es hängt wie immer davon ab was man machen will ja
aber wpf ist wenn aus außen lieb und ist auch nicht sonderlich modernt es ist nur
minimal moderner als windows forms
es kann auch nicht wirklich aus heutigen gesichtspunkten so und so viel
mehr was man heute brauchen würde im vergleich zu windows forms ich war
natürlich wpf hatte riesen neues rendering back end auf direkt x basis und
haste nicht gesehen und sonst was also für die damalige zeit war es schon viel
aber es trotzdem heute hoffnungslos hoffnungslos veraltet du hast den wpf
anwendung beispielsweise textelement die noch nicht mal emoji support haben also
kannst du es noch nicht mal also nicht mal color emojis drinne verwenden weil
eben dass der uralt uralt front renderer ist der da drinne benutzt wird und
schrift antialasing hat in wpf auch noch nie richtig gut funktioniert seit
anfang an bis heute also nie wpf finde ich nicht so nice
microsoft selbst hat ja auch kein bock mehr auf wpf die machen jetzt maui
beziehungsweise unter windows ist es da unten drunter win ui allerdings muss ich
ehrlich sagen maui ist auch nicht so mein fall maui ist quasi xamarin 2.0 und
das hat mir schon nicht gefallen wenn ich in dort nett ein cross platform ui
machen müsste heutzutage dann würde ich wahrscheinlich das hier probieren
habe ich übrigens aufgeschrieben wollte ich mir demnächst auch mal im
stream angucken
läuft unter mac linux windows
und ich glaube damit würde ich glücklicher werden als maui so wirklich
geil finde ich aber xml xml zeug immer noch nett wenn ich ehrlich bin also ich
werde damit wahrscheinlich nicht wahr werden warum es auch unbedingt
unbedingt xml sein musste ich weiß nicht klar kann man jetzt sagen html ist ja im
prinzip auch xml
es ist halt doof dass das beste was es gibt für cross platform tatsächlich so
ein scheiß wie elektron ist
sagt halt ein bisschen mal gucken mal gucken wann flatter desktop richtig gut
funktioniert der focus der focus bei flatter liegt ja eindeutig eher auf
mobile ja cute ist wirklich gut also cute es gefällt mir von den ganzen
cross platform frameworks wenn es wirklich native sein soll am besten
allerdings ist es halt z plus plus ja ich weiß es gibt auch gute pyson bindings
am ende kommste da irgendwie bei z plus plus raus ja also leider ist ist native
desktop ui entwicklung scheiße glaube anders kann man das nicht sagen was
meint ihr denn warum so viele anwendungen heutzutage schlicht und
begreifend einfach in desktop fenster gerappte browser anwendungen sind aus
dem grund und dann ist microsoft nicht ganz unschuldig dran
weil microsoft hat es die letzten 15 jahre über mega verkackt die haben erst
angefangen mit ihrem komischen javascript basiert im zeug für win 8 und
uwp und dann uwp 2.0 und dann irgendwann nach uwp ist doch kacke wir
machen win ui aber wir machen win ui mit allen nachteilen von uwp und jetzt
gibt es endlich win ui 3 aber das ist auch noch nicht richtig fertig wenn es
unpacked applications es ist es ist für art also microsoft hat es da richtig
verkackt
aber selbst nicht cross platform selbst windows only gibt es ja nichts gescheites
das ist ja das dumme also das ist einfach nur einfach nur schrott also
microsoft an den letzten jahren über veranstaltet hat also wahrscheinlich ist
das beste wirklich entweder cute oder elektron so blöd klingt vielleicht
vielleicht in zukunft flatter
und bei allen anderen sachen müsste man mal schauen ob man dann da auch wirklich
gut mit klarkommt auch wenn man vielleicht so ein bisschen advance
andere sachen braucht oder so ein paar edge cases hat tauri das ist doch auch
browser krempel nur dass es eben kein extra chrome mitbringt sondern die
jeweilige betriebssystem plattform nimmt da hast du dann aber wahrscheinlich
wieder andere probleme
mac only ist gut ja ich habe ok hören sagen und was ich was ich lese ich
entwickelt keine mac anwendung aber was das angeht kann man wohl apple da
nichts nichts vorwerfen das ist seit jahren wohl ganz gut native mac und ios
entwicklung maui geht doch auch native ja aber maui ist kacke maui ist ja quasi
nur einen rapper wenn du so willst maui nimmt immer das was microsoft als die
beste technologie für die jeweilige plattform auserkoren hat also maui nimmt
unten drunter unter windows wahrscheinlich mittel ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher aber
ich gehe mal davon aus dass es dass es mittlerweile so ist win ui wahrscheinlich
kann sie noch in den legacy uwp mode aktivieren unter linux ist es gtk
wobei das nicht offiziell ist maui unterstützt nämlich gar kein linux
offiziell und unter mac ist es halt ja das wie kokor ist es glaube ich oder wie
heißt wie heißt das zeug unter meck für guia anwendung
ok wir lassen uns jetzt von ihm noch mal belehren warum das warum das alles viel
viel besser ist
also das sind fast 50 prozent schneller oder sowas
weißt du was das beste ist dass die nicht clean code variante sogar noch für
mich in dem fall besser zu lesen ist deswegen würde ich auch gar nicht so
weit gehen und sagen das erste ist unbedingt die clean code variante also
wenn es darum geht dass es gut lesbar ist finde ich die zweite variante in dem
fall viel angenehmer
ok
Ja, es ist ja auch bloatet as fuck.
Okay, das kann man so machen, wobei ich sagen muss, an der Stelle wird es dann schon langsam, aber sicher ein bisschen
ein bisschen unübersichtlich vielleicht, wenn man es so macht. Ich meine, solange das hier noch oben drüber steht,
dann ist das kein großartiges Ding. Da wird es vielleicht schon ein bisschen schwieriger.
Man könnte an der Stelle vielleicht echt einen Functioncall machen, wo das dann drinnen definiert ist,
in der Funktion, nicht hier irgendwie global. Ja, irgendwie so eine Kalk-Area-Funktion, wo das dann drinnen steht.
Und das hier würde ich dann auch in der Variable zuweisen, also ich würde das hier oben rausholen, irgendwie zuweisen.
Und das dann in die, was würde ich, war, was ist das hier, war, keine Ahnung, wie man das hier nennen kann, war, blub, gleich, das da.
Und dann unten würde ich dann blub mal shape width, blub mal shape height. Ja, aber ich meine, da fängt es schon langsam aber sicher an,
ein bisschen unübersichtlich zu werden.
Pass auf, noch schneller. Massive, achtmal schneller.
Huge speed increase. Jetzt läuft darauf der Switch.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ohne Scheiß, so ähnlich wie hier, wir sind bei 12.10, so ähnlich wie hier hätte das jeder Python-Programmierer auch gemacht.
Ein Dictionary angelegt, jetzt nicht mit globalen Variablen, ein Dictionary angelegt, und dann, also quasi, der hätte wahrscheinlich ein Dictionary angelegt, shape type zu Nummer.
Und dann hat er geguckt, welcher shape type kommt da rein und hätte das so, ich finde, das ist eigentlich eine sinnvolle Variante, kann man auch so ganz gut lesen.
Also ich finde, man kann meistens sagen, umso kompakter es ist, umso besser kann man es lesen, wobei das ab einer gewissen Kompaktheit aufhört.
Also wenn man dann anfängt Variablenamen zu kürzen, nur dass es noch kompakter wird, wenn man Newlines rausnimmt, nur dass es noch kompakter wird, wenn man verschiedene Dinge komplizierter macht, nur dass es noch kompakter wird, dann nicht.
Aber in der Regel ist es einfacher, wenn du die Funktionalität in fünf Zeilen packst, als in 30, weil 30 Zeilen zu überblicken, was passiert da eigentlich, schlicht und ergreifend komplizierter ist, als das, wenn du einfach drauf guckst, okay.
Hier ist easy, sofort offensichtlich, was passiert. Und bei dem ganzen Hin und Hergespringe, sonst über 30 Zeilen eher nicht.
Naja, eine weitere Sache, man muss halt auch ein bisschen doof hier, weil das ist halt auch wieder so eine C++-Geschichte, eine Low-Level-Geschichte.
Das hier ist ja wahrscheinlich nur so eine Art Array, weil es hier auch ShapeCount ist, also sprich in ShapeType steht dann eine Nummer drin, die mit dem ArrayIndex übereinstimmen muss, dass es funktioniert.
Das würdest du zum Beispiel jetzt in irgendeinem Python-Dictionary, hättest du das einfacher, dann würdest du nämlich wirklich ein Dictionary machen, ShapeType zu Nummer. Ja gut, das wäre dann nicht so schnell, weil ein Array ist immer noch das schnellste, was es gibt.
Ah gut, 12c.
Also wie gesagt, für mich ist es clean, wenn es gut lesbar ist und der Sinn schnell erkennbar ist. Das ist für mich, ob das dann irgendwelche super krassen Clean-Code-Guidelines folgt oder so.
Wenn das kompakt ist, gut zu verstehen ist, ist das für mich clean genug. Und wir wissen ja, Hauptsache es muss fehlerfrei sein.
Just fehlerfrei programmieren, vorher.
Ist Punkt 2 nicht Information Hiding? Ja, sowas in der Richtung wollte er uns glaube ich damit sagen, dass er jetzt direkt quasi Informationen benutzt aus dem Typ als Index für das Array, anstatt dass der Typ das irgendwie selber macht.
So, 10x, wir können nicht mehr mit dem Handy benutzen. Wenn wir uns an desktops anschauen, ist ein 10x-Speed-Einprüfung, wie wenn es von der normalen CPU-Marke heute geht, bis nach der normalen CPU-Marke von 2010.
Weißt du nicht, ob man das so sagen kann?
Es kommt ja auf den Anwendungsfall an. Es gibt ja durchaus Anwendungsfälle, da ist es nicht so wichtig, ob das jetzt in 40 Nanosekunden oder in 400 Nanosekunden durch ist.
Je nachdem, was da ist. Dazu kommt allerdings, wo ich ihm tatsächlich recht geben würde, ich finde die letzten beiden Beispiele sogar besser als die ursprünglichen Clean-Code-Beispiele, weil sie für mich cleaner aussehen und besser zu lesen sind.
Doing the simplest possible operation, right?
I mean, we are doing these two things by default, because all we're doing is computing the area and it'd be very difficult to figure out how you could make a large function out of computing the area because it's just like a multiplication or two.
What if we add one more aspect to our problem, just one, so that we can follow these two rules of Clean-Code and see how much worse the Clean-Code gets.
Chet, da habt ihr recht, da habt ihr recht, dass früher teilweise auch deutlich mehr optimiert wurde und auf Kleinigkeiten gedacht wurde. Mein Lieblingsbeispiel ist Dings hier, Rollercoaster Tycoon. Das erste, das hier, das ist zum größten Teil von Hunt in Assembler programmiert.
Könnt ihr euch das vorstellen? Da musst du absolut Gigafivehead sein, um sowas in Assembler zu bauen.
Das war zum größten Teil handoptimiert, also das Rendering und alles weiß ich nicht genau, aber das unter der Haube ist handoptimiert, das Assembler.
Das ist richtig krass, also der ist richtig feifett. Das kannst du natürlich bei vielen, das stimmt schon, das kannst du bei vielen Games heute in der Art und Weise natürlich nicht machen.
Du kannst jetzt nicht anfangen bei irgendeinem aktuellen AAA-Game in Unreal da im großen Stil handoptimiertes Assembler, weil da wirst du ja nicht fertig.
An manchen Stellen ist es sicherlich immer noch sinnvoll, wenn du irgendwas hast, was jeden, jedes Bild oder es muss doch nicht mal jedes Bild sein.
Heute passieren da durchaus Sachen nicht nur im Bildrhythmus, also quasi was bei jedem Durchlauf, bei jedem Ding jedes Mal benutzt wird.
Und du rufst das so oft auf, dann macht das durchaus heute noch Sinn, denke ich mal, auch wenn du spielst eine Unreal-Programme, um irgendwelche handoptimierten Assembler-Sachen zu bauen.
Ja, in Unreal intern ist denke ich jede Menge, tatsächlich jede Menge optimiertes Assembler-Zeug drin.
War Unreal nicht den Clean-Code?
Ich glaube wir wollen intern gar nicht wissen, wie Unreal aussieht, da schlummern bestimmt auch sehr abartige Dinge drinne.
Ok, pass auf, was kommt als nächstes? 100% Performance Increase.
Woher kommt dieses Clean-Code?
Das sind Regeln, die er hier aufgreift, die so im Internet rumschwirren, das sind die offiziellen Beispiele wohl davon, so sieht Clean-Code aus und das greift er hier auf.
Es gibt ja schon seit einer ganzen Weile so diese, ich weiß gar nicht ob das offiziell unter Clean-Code läuft, ja, so diese Sachen mit Solid und Dry und was hast du denn ansonsten noch alles drinne?
Und so ein paar dieser Punkte, die er am Anfang zeigt, gibt es dafür eine Norm? Nee, ich glaube eine Norm nicht, aber so ein paar mehr oder weniger offizielle, halboffizielle Guidelines.
Nee, das ist wieder was anderes.
Bei denen geht es ums Implementieren von oft gebrauchten Mustern, Patterns, ja, so Subscriber zum Beispiel, so wie mit Twitch Prime, Observer-Pattern und Factories und sowas, da geht es darum.
Da geht es nicht unbedingt um Clean-Code.
Okay, Huge Speed Increase kommt jetzt wieder.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir aber so langsam in die Region, wo ich sage, jetzt wird es langsam ein bisschen schwierig lesbar.
Jetzt fällt es mir schon ein bisschen schwer hier durchzublicken, was es da eigentlich geht, ja. Meine blöde Frage, warum rechnet er dann hier plus eins?
Achso, weil er null Komma irgendwas dann raushaben will, oder?
Eins plus, wahrscheinlich, dass hier nicht null rauskommen kann, oder? Ist das hier, dass er null vermeidet? Ja, das ist, dass er null vermeidet, weil wenn hier null rauskommt, dann rechnet er hier einzeln durch null und es geht kaputt.
Also, ich finde es sonderlich gut lesbar, ist es jetzt an der Stelle hier aber nett.
Okay, ich blicke jetzt nicht, ich habe schon wieder den Faden verloren, was er uns eigentlich genau jetzt sagen will, also lass mal Bench Bar Ergebnisse gucken.
Da habe ich mit gerechnet, dass er zu dem Fazit kommt.
Und sie ist einfacher zu lesen.
Okay, weiter.
Dann jetzt, ah den kenne ich, der macht gute Videos. Der Nick, der macht gute Videos.
Mir reicht es ehrlich gesagt.
Also, ich gebe ihm da schon in großen Teilen recht, einfach blind irgendwelchen Rules, die irgendwelche Leute im Internet aufgestellt haben zu followen und dann zu sagen, ah jetzt ist es clean, obwohl es einfach nur bloated as fuck ist, muss nicht sein.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was der Hacker News zu sagt.
893 Comments, das dachte ich mir, das dachte ich mir, dass die da nicht so scharf draus sind.
Was mich interessiert ist, wenn ich nach Rust suche. Leute, was meint ihr, ich suche jetzt nach Rust, wie oft wird Rust auf dieser Seite gefunden? Moment Moment, load more Comments, load more Comments, load more Comments.
Okay, wie oft wird Rust gefunden? Was? Moment, da fehlt doch jetzt die Hälfte. Wait a minute, ne ne ne, da stimmt was nicht. Hacker News ist wieder kacke.
Rust, acht, ne Moment, vielleicht soll ich ja Rust. Wie? Nur zwei Mal? Was ist da los? Sieben Mal? Okay, sieben Mal?
Neun Mal? Okay, jetzt kommen sie erst richtig in Fahrt. Bei den letzten fünfzehn nicht. Also irgendwie so dreißig Mal oder so.
Hey Guys, das ist Christian und wenn ihr... Morgen, morgen, nicht jetzt.
Must no terminal commands. Grab, hui, advanceder shit.
So. Dann machen wir jetzt Schluss, Leute. Da hatten wir heute ja heute ziemlich 50-50 Stream. 50% Handy gucken, 50% random talk.
Gerade reingekommen. Ja, den letzten trifft immer irgendeiner, der als letztes reinkommt.
Was? Trackmania? Guck ich nicht. Kein Trackmania.
Alert, so ist was gut. Danke für die ganzen Subs, Leute. Ich habe bestimmt wieder die Hälfte übersehen.
Hab ich auch. Aber ich glaube auch. Wen haben wir denn hier noch? Edelknecht und Schixi. Danke für den Sub.
Keck Wade. Sind nur Follows. Keck Wade. Verguckt. Dann habe ich doch nichts übersehen. Panda, dich habe ich übersehen. Dankeschön.
Panda, Doomswap. Danke für den Sub. Echt gar nicht gesehen.
Okay.
Okay, Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis dann. Tschüss.